the greatest relationship that you could
ever have is with yourself taking time
to be in the presence of yourself and
ask yourself important questions like
are you happy who am I and instead of
getting up and getting on your cell
phone and getting distracted sit with
your triple filtered water or a glass of
wine or whatever you're into the
question without being distracted the
contemplation process is the building
process neurologically and for me I was
I'm a guy who loves God I'm a guy who
loves a Divine I'm a guy who loves
mystery I'm the guy who just never stops
dovetailing information that's just me
and I never really planned on doing any
of this I mean my theory is on life is
make it up as you go along and take the
value and run and what the bleep became
a sensation and all of a sudden I went
from a normal guy to being a rock star
and I was traveling around the world and
doing conferences all over the place I
reached this point where I realized that
I wasn't living the work and that really
bothered me I was disturbed by that I
was really uncomfortable and when you
get uncomfortable and nothing's making
that discomfort go away it's time to
evolve it's time to make a different
choice and I clearly heard in my head
during one meditation stop making the
same choices and pause I didn't know
what that meant except that I knew that
I was relying on all of this external
stimulation to build an identity that I
really wasn't and then I had to show up
for people and look a certain way and
act a certain way and that wasn't me and
it got disturbing for me and I didn't
make time for myself and make time to be
the example I mean my motive is always
be the example of everything that I
teach I shouldn't be leading in my
clinic I don't live those principles
myself if I don't live my life that way
and hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because as a young
entrepreneur I struggled to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today let's
get some incredible motivation from the
one and only Joe dispenza enjoy
the height of my popularity I
disappeared I canceled all my
events my friends thought I was on crack
or something they thought I lost my mind
because you know what they were saying
you could make so much money and I said
I don't really I know how to make money
I really don't care about money I really
don't care about how happy I'm gonna be
with myself
and I broke from the world for six
months and retreated
and I really decided that if I presented
myself back to the world that I wasn't
going to be seduced by it in the same
way
that I really wanted to be the example
of everything that I taught and I wanted
to lead events in a way that empowered
people I never wanted it to be about me
I wanted to be about you most people try
to create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work we
literally have to become someone else in
other words thoughts are the language of
the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how you think and how you feel
creates a state of being so most people
have experiences in their life that
brand them emotionally they feel fear
they feel anger they feel bitterness
they feel frustration they feel
insecurity and those emotions then
become part of their identity
so once they think certain thoughts that
turn on certain circuits in their brain
that are equal to their insecurity and
then they feel insecure the moment they
feel insecure they think more insecure
thoughts which makes more chemicals for
them to feel insecure
and the repetition of that cycle over
time conditions the body to
subconsciously become the mind of
insecurity so then the person says I am
insecure
and whenever you say I am anything
you're commanding your mind and body
towards a destiny so then most peoples
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness
you're not waiting for your new
relationship to feel love you're not
waiting for the mystical moment to feel
awe you're not waiting for your success
to feel empowered that's the old model
of reality of cause and effect in other
words
the materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur
we have to feel love for ourselves and
love for life in order for us to have
love in our life and so then to instruct
people how to teach their body
emotionally how that future could feel
like before it's made manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred so the
process of change
and the meditative model requires
unlearning and relearning requires
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self what we say in
Neuroscience pruning synaptic
connections and sprouting new
connections unfiring and unwiring and
re-firing and rewiring
unmemorizing emotions that are stored in
the body and then reconditioning the
body to a new mind into a new motion no
longer signaling the same genes in the
same way but signaling new genes in new
ways
beginning to pull your energy out of the
past and beginning to invest your energy
into the future the concept of
transformation is a really important
message and and we use meditation as
the mechanism because I want people to
become so familiar with their old
personality self that they don't default
anymore and keep reaffirming that new
personality it's so much easier to
forget that Vision than to remember so
you gotta constantly remind yourself
reproduce the same level of line you
gotta constantly emotionally embrace it
keep conditioning the body the thought
and the feeling the image and the
emotion the stimulus and response your
conditioning your body into the future
instead of waking up every morning and
remembering your problems and those
problems are associated with people and
objects of things at certain times and
places and every one of those problems
as an emotional associate so people are
remembering their past and they're
feeling the emotions they're firing and
wiring the same circuits and feeling the
same ocean they're conditioning their
body into the past and that's why change
is so hard
because the moment you step out from
doing the same thing and making a
different choice there's going to be
some discomfort because the body
subconsciously has been programmed
emotionally into the past
so the moment you make a different
Choice you're stepping out of the known
into the unknown the body starts
influencing the mind to return back to
the familiar place that's why people
have difficulty changing and yet if
meditation is the model
to become so familiar with your old self
and so familiar with your new self how
many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment called
change okay give people the tools and
let them practice and they'll actually
start enjoying it okay but if
you're not being defined by a vision of
the future
I assert you're left with the memories
of the past and you'll be predictable in
your life so you wake up in the morning
you see your co-worker you see your
husband you see you're on a zoom call
you're picking up your cell phone for
most people it's the environment that's
actually causing them to think and feel
equal to everything that they know
so it's not their personality that's
creating their personal reality it's
their personal reality that's
reaffirming their personality it's their
environment that's controlling the way
they feel and the way they think why
because every person
your husband your co-workers your your
employees
your dog your cell phone every one of
those things you have a neurological
Network that you've actually created
because you've experienced them because
you've experienced them you have an
emotion associated with them so if we're
not being defined by a vision of the
future when we see the same people and
go to the same places and we do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
the environment is controlling the way
we feel and the way we think but of how
we think and how we feel actually
creates our life as long as we're
thinking equal to everything that we
know everything stays the same because
nothing changes in our life until we
change okay so the conditioning process
the thought and the feeling the memory
and the emotion you're thinking in the
past when you remember your problems you
feel the emotion associated with it
you're conditioning your body to become
the mind of that emotion and it's so
objective it's believing it's living the
same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year and
now you're headed in a very specific
genetic outcome
okay you get up you get up in the
morning you do the same thing as you did
yesterday you go through this whole
routine and you keep doing that your
body's on autopilot now and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions is
acquired through repetition habit is
when you've done something so many times
the body actually knows not to do it
better than your conscious mind that
means your body is the mind it's
dragging you into that predictable
future based on what you did in the past
and you lost your free will to a set of
programs I think that the greatest
belief that you could have is the belief
in yourself and when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
and when you believe in possibilities
you have to believe in yourself
so people that enter this work
come with a certain amount of chronic
disbelief that they could actually
change their life or change their health
condition
when you see the scientific research
that in seven days a novice meditator
their biology literally looks like
they're in a different life and they're
in a ballroom and there's nothing very
special about a ballroom I've been to
thousands of ballrooms and the
environment isn't that stimulating that
those changes are coming from within you
see the data and you look at how cancer
cells
actually the energy in cancer cells when
you take the plasma of meditators
advanced meditators and you subject that
plasma to all kinds of cancer cells
seventy percent of the mitochondrial
function actually diminishes in the
cancer cell cancer cells love to
multiply and they love to move you take
energy out of the cancer cell you're
taking life out of the cancer cell and
people see that data it gives them hope
it gives them the idea that it's
possible now
when someone stands on the stage with
stage four cancer that has spread to
their bones to the uterus to their lungs
to the liver to all the tissues of their
body and you ask any physician who's
seen stage four cancer in Bones it's
very unlikely you're going to see a
reversal and you see the person stand on
the stage and tell their story and it's
not glamorous it's a real life story
and there's no evidence of cancer in any
of her tissues any longer no cancer in
her bones the pet scans show that
there's a complete reversal
that's the four minute mile that's the
person speaking the truth and invariably
somebody in the audience is examining
that person's story
and they're thinking if that person can
do it I can do it as well also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there being victimized by a circumstance
in your life literally means that that
event that circumstance that person that
condition is actually causing you to
feel emotionally and think in terms of
memories equal to that circumstance and
that circumstances actually changes your
state of being so you're thinking the
same way and you're feeling the same way
in response to the environment is the
same we can guarantee that your life is
going to stay the same because you're
the same yes that person why are you
unhappy why are you frustrated why are
you sad they'll say the this condition
this this person is actually making me
feel and think this way well anything
that makes us feel and think a certain
way that we don't think we have any
control over for the most part we're
victims so we're as a species become
victimized by the conditions in our life
and it's the environment then that is
controlling the way we feel and the way
we think so the idea is if you can
change the way you think and change the
way you feel
could you begin to produce outcomes or
effects in your life that cause you to
believe that you're the creator of your
life instead of the victim of your life
which means then you would have to think
greater than that circumstance and you
would have to feel differently in the
presence of that circumstance and if you
truly could
and begin to create an outcome the
synchronicity the Serendipity the
coincidence that happens in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to realize that
on some level you had a hand in that you
know that you're a participant in that
our interest is to teach people how to
to reverse that process
every person every circumstance every
condition every place every object that
you own is mapped neurologically in your
brain so your brain is a record of the
past it's it's an artifact the
repository of everything you've learned
intellectually your experience and
products of experience are called
emotions the memories that we have in
our life produces familiar emotions or
our response to anybody that we know in
our life there's a neurological Network
for your boss for your co-worker for
your ex and for most people they're
they're interaction in the environment
is causing their environment to control
their thinking or their personal reality
is controlling their personality so our
interests to see us of oh if your
personality is made of how you think how
you act and how you feel
is it possible if I begin to change the
way I think change the way I act and
change the way life I feel should my
life change because I'm changing and so
the interest for us then is to be able
to meet the challenges and conditions in
our life from a greater level of
Consciousness and and not be victimized
by those circumstances but to take time
and and to review how you're going to
think how you're going to act and how
you're going to feel that's meditation
and review how you're not going to think
you know how you're not going to act and
how you're not going to feel it just
turns out that tends to be 95 percent of
who we are as those unconscious programs
so it's so much easier to forget than to
remember because it's the majority of
who we are you know after a certain
point in our life so changing that
process the overcoming process of that
same self somehow begins to produce a
facts in people's lives and that's
that's kind of the exciting part about
being a creator of your life I always
tell my children that your personality
creates your personal reality and if you
want to change something in your life
then on a fundamental level you have to
look at the thoughts you're thinking to
see if they're serving you notice the
behaviors and that you're demonstrating
and see if those are loving to yourself
and begin to look at the emotions that
you've memorized that become part of
your identity and children begin to
understand this very naturally because
the law with children
that I've believed from the time my
children were very young is that if you
give them the facts they will interpret
the laws so because of mirror neurons
your children are paying attention to
more of what you do than what you say
so you can't say to your kids clean your
room and have a messy room you
understand because they're going to want
they're going to look at your room
subconsciously automatically
and I was uh interviewing doing an
interview for this book someone's
interviewing for me for this book and
they said can you tell me about the
terrible twos I said it's really simple
what do you do the first uh year of your
child's life
oh look how cute he is look how cute she
is look oh and then all of a sudden at
one years old what happens
they stand up right and they stand up
and their brain is so neuroplastic and
they go wow look at this base I wonder
how it's made oh it holds water and then
it begins the child begins to interact
with the environment out of curiosity
pulling things breaking things and then
what do you do
no
you do that for a whole year and then
you say at two years old put your shoes
on and what's the child say no
no that's mirror neurons it's only
mirroring Behavior
so we know then that
children pay attention because of those
mirror neurons more based on what they
observe than what they're told every
time you learn something new you make
new Connections in your brain that's
what learning is learning is forging new
synaptic connections
and as you begin to leave imprints in
your neurological tissue as a result of
your interaction in the environment
the next thing is that you're going to
have an opportunity then to apply that
information
to personalize it to demonstrate it
and a certain people group of people
will get their behaviors to match their
intentions to get their actions equal to
their thoughts they'll step out into the
unknown
and we'll try it and when they do
they'll have a new experience
and experience then enriches the brain
reorganizing more circuits than what you
understood physiologically
but the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and the moment you feel Unlimited
the moment you feel like a patient
parent the moment you feel abundant the
moment you feel free
now you are teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood
so we can say knowledge is for the mind
and experiences for the body
and in that moment you're beginning to
embody the truth of that philosophy of
that theory and you're literally
signaling new genes in new ways and you
are rewriting your biological program
but if you've done it once
it must mean you can do it again
and if you can repeat any experience
over and over again you are going to
neurochemically condition your mind and
body to begin to work as one
and when you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it as well as the mind now it's becoming
innate in you
it's second nature it's easy it's
familiar
it's who you are
as a matter of fact you've practiced it
so many times that you don't even have
to consciously think about it because
it's becoming a subconscious program
so our job
is to go from philosopher
to initiate to master
from knowledge to experience to wisdom
from mind to body to Soul
from thinking to doing to being to
learning it with your head practicing it
with your hands and knowing it by heart
I think this particular time in history
people are waking up to possibilities
and you have to admit that when you
become aware of something that didn't
exist before there's a change in
Consciousness and so I think people
because of information at this current
time in history are just more informed
and because they're more informed
they're more conscious of possibilities
and and and so
when you take a group of people and you
give them sound scientific information
and as you as you said science to me is
the Contemporary language of mysticism
that that science can demystify the
mystical
and if you can combine a Quantum model
of reality that says that somehow
you're connected to everything that your
thoughts have an effect on the nature of
reality and if mind is an important
element of that then we better study and
understand what mind is so if you can
combine some Neuroscience some
neuroendocrinology with some
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection in epigenetics that says that
you're not doomed by your genes to be a
certain way your entire life that you
could actually change your Gene
Expressions I wanted to listen to the
questions that people asked and the
questions were okay you create your
reality I get it how do you do it
I thought it was a brilliant question
next question is okay your personality
creates your personal reality your
personality is made with how you think
how you act and how you feel if I want
to change my personal reality I got to
change my personality nothing changes in
my life till I change how do we change
why is it so hard to change and then the
last question was what do you do
and so we started teaching these events
you know around the world and and giving
people some tools and basic neuroscience
and epigenetics and brain waves and
electromagnetism building a model and
you know at the end of an event people
would say I I feel a little better you
know I have a better sense of well-being
but we weren't seeing any dramatic
changes in people's health and then it
took about a year
and we just I was running these events
and every time I'd run an event someone
would say can you do another one
somebody did a more evolved version and
then we did another evolve version and
then I said I don't know anything else
I don't know anything else and then I
started having profound mystical
experiences and that changed my view of
the world dramatically and I remember at
one event
this woman with Ms sitting in a
wheelchair after one meditation stood up
out of that throne and started dancing
around
and when I saw that happening I knew
something had to be taking place
inwardly in her in other words
there must have been some Gene
regulation
that happened as a result of her inner
process and that's when everything
changed for me that's when I got a team
of scientists and neuroscientists and
biologists and partnered with heart math
Institute we started building this model
of understanding of 18 000 brain scans
now
the thousands and thousands of HR V
measurements we got Gene testing that's
done telomere testing that's not immune
regulation you know thousands of
different metabolites at this point I I
wanted to see if that person's
subjective experience of whatever that
was could be calibrated objectively and
once we understood that information can
we teach transformation better
and if you can do it and capture that
information and teach transformation
better you can shorten the distance
between really the thought and the
experience of what a person wants and
and I think that the science has become
the Contemporary language to demystify
that process and once you use tradition
or culture religion
divide an audience but science creates
community and people want to use that as
a language now it's the Contemporary
language you communicate with your
patients in terms of science I mean how
many people here run a clinic and the
first thing you say to a patient when
they start talking about their health
condition is that's not true I used to
say that every day that's not true that
is not the truth
so then that information then that
people are beginning to understand is is
theoretical and philosophical and now
there's too many testimonials I mean
we're just talking backstage every
single day we have something that
challenges my belief
that challenge is my belief in what's
possible and when I see the scientists
running the same
study over and over again
he's running the same study five times
over again then changing the study and
running it a different way and getting
the same result I know he's changing his
belief right there I know she's changing
her belief they're looking for something
else to occur and actually doesn't this
is new information it's a discovery the
majority of the thoughts that we think
every single day are the same thoughts
as we thought yesterday
and in fact ninety percent of them are
and the same thoughts leading to the
same choices the same choices leading to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
creating the same experiences and the
same experiences producing the same
feelings and emotions
begins to cause our biology
to become very similar very same and
the repetition of that and firing and
wiring then creates automatic programs
in the brain and body and 95 of who we
are is a state of unconscious or
subconscious programs where we've done
something so many times that the body
now can actually do it automatically
without the conscious mind if you truly
wanted to change and you understood that
your personality creates your personal
reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
and the present personality who's
listening to this call has created the
present personal reality called their
life
that means if they wanted to create a
new personal reality a new life they
would have to begin to change their
personality they'd have to change
themselves and most people then try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality it doesn't work
so then if you're sitting in your
meditation and you ask yourself the
question who do I want to be when I open
my eyes what is the greatest expression
of myself
and you said okay let me remind myself
of how I no longer want to think
you know the thoughts like
whatever it's too hard I'll never change
I'll never get what I want let me become
so conscious
of those unconscious thoughts that I
wouldn't let that thought slit by my
awareness today unnoticed by me and
program my autonomic nervous system in
the specific outcome
none of you said how would I want to
speak today
how do I want to act how do I want to
behave and you reminded yourself how you
weren't going to act and how you weren't
going to behave and you became conscious
of those unconscious habits to such a
degree you wouldn't go unconscious and
behave in the same way that's when
you're no longer the program now your
Consciousness observing the program if
you said when is my energy drop when
when what do I feel when I feel those
typical familiar emotions what are they
uh so let me name them just so I'm so
aware of them that my energy drops I can
catch myself in that moment and not
return back to the same familiar
emotions
and cause my body to believe it's back
in the past and we can't see a new
future from the past so that process
then
is what I call getting beyond the old
self and it's a disentangling from the
program the word meditation means to
become familiar with so as you sit there
and become familiar with those states of
Mind and Body you begin to objectify
your subjective self now now you are you
are becoming so aware of the unconscious
programs you won't go unconscious and
that's the first step to change and then
what if you said what thoughts do I want
to fire and wire in my brain what
thoughts do I want to put my attention
behind and begin to install the new
circuitry the new hardware and if I keep
my attention on it and I fire and wire
those thoughts it's going to begin to
become a software program and that's
going to be the new voice in my head
that's going to be the voice that's
telling me a new program that you can
that it is possible what we learned when
we started studying brains what we were
doing pre and post measurements and
we've got thousands and thousands of
brain scans
we have real-time brain scans too and
when I started seeing people
whose brains were getting worse during a
meditation
I said to them what are you doing in
there
and a hundred percent of the time
they were analyzing their life
or themselves within some disturbing
emotion
and if emotions are the record of the
past and those emotions are derived from
the hormones of stress
they were thinking in the past and I
learned right in that moment that if I
got a person past the emotion across the
river of change with me forget about the
emotion just keep overcoming it forget
about the past dragging people out of
their past is the work
and so
when we started studying those brains
and we started seeing changes of pre and
post measurements I realized the change
wasn't just in their mind
was actually in their brain
in that we were measuring different
compartments of the brain and when we're
living in stress and we're living in
survival when the brain is aroused into
those High beta brainwave patterns and
we're out of balance and we're trying to
predict and control everything in our
life and we're shifting our attention
from one person to another person to
another problem to another thing to
another condition every person every
object every thing every place has a
neurological Network in your brain I've
got small field of vision I have very I
have no peripheral vision in Marathi not
being able to see on this side at all
and then today when I was walking it
took me a long time to get into it and
then I thought okay I'm just going to
probably halfway through I thought I'm
just going to walk with purpose
and walk like a person that can see and
then I can't remember the rest of it
until I got to the end and then when I
was walking back
there was like the trees around and not
flat
and I can see my hand
which is a little taste sister now is
she beautiful
isn't she is it can you relate with her
she's not like a movie star she's not
buffed you know she doesn't look she
doesn't have the perfect everything that
people think it has to be that way she
looks just like you and you can relate
with her yes and because you're looking
at evidence this is evidence she has
depth perception now she just decided
she made up her mind to go all in to
walk as somebody that was that had sight
she got so wrapped up in the action that
she forgot about herself she's walking
right into her future self she's walking
right in she's becoming her future self
that's part of your dream is it not she
walked into her future she came back to
her senses her senses were working
better
and all she did was get a biological
upgrade by getting Beyond herself you
better be walking like anything's
possible you better become the very
person you want to be and get so
involved in it did you forget about
space and time and that's exactly what
happened to her she unified with the
unified field she overcame some aspect
of her limited self to join their
greater self she lost herself in nothing
she lost herself in the act and became
something else when she came back to her
senses she took a piece of that energy
with her and she got a biological
upgrade all she had to do was become
that person she's a different
personality right in front of you than
the personality that started this day
today she's somebody else and it's
reflected in her biology and all she did
was make up her mind to do it meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation I think
there's two times the door to the
subconscious mind opens up when we wake
up in the morning
and we go to bed at night and it's
simple brain chemistry and simple
physiology we have a circadian rhythm as
soon as there's light our body has been
pretty much programmed yeah that we
begin to release serotonin different
chemicals that kind of wake us up so our
brain waves go from Delta to Theta to
Alpha to Beta And you kind of slide up
this way and then you're back to
conscious awareness local in space and
time when you go to bed at night
you go from beta to Alpha to Theta to
Delta and you slide down now
if you're stressed
uh you can't stop thinking you stay in
beta and you you're thinking actually is
arousing the body because you're
thinking about your problems you can't
slide down right so those two points uh
in the day when you wake up in the
morning go to bed at night
um when we're and when alpha or our
analytical facilities are suppressed
we're in Theta we're in a hypnotic state
and the door between the conscious mind
on the subconscious mind is wide open
what separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind is the
analytical mind so as you suppress
analytical facilities you can program
anybody to do anything
so then
what really happens for most people
before they even reach for their cell
phone and by the way the statistics are
86 of the people in the western world
first thing first thing they do is they
reach for the cell phone and they
connect to everything that's known and
why is that a problem
well I would never tell people how to
think but I would give them information
to cause them to think so the device is
reminding them
of things that are known and every
person every object everything every
place is mapped neurologically in our
brain because we've experienced it and
then we have an emotion associated with
our co-worker with our boss with our ex
with our whoever and so the moment we
start responding
now we start feeling the same way
so now the environment
is actually controlling the person's
feelings and thoughts yeah and anything
that controls the way we feel in the way
we think we're victims too
so something's programming us to think
and feel a certain way there's nothing
wrong with that you can you should check
your tax but do whatever you need to do
but the first thing in the morning if
the door between the conscious mind the
subconscious mind is open
why don't we program a new Behavior why
don't we rehearse a different way of
being with our children with our spouse
in our Zoom meetings when we're alone
when we're in traffic is there a better
way to evolve our experience so if
you're truly in the game of evolution
you're truly in the game like one
lifetime one day what am I working on
today can I respond different way to
this person can I think this way instead
of that way let me be conscious of my
unconscious thoughts let me not
be in a habit let me stay away from
certain emotions let me practice feeling
these emotions see if I can maintain it
now you're in the game you're out of the
bleachers and you're on the playing
field so
it actually happens even before the cell
phone because what most people do is
they wake up and the first thing they do
is the brain is a record of the past
they think other problems and those
problems are just memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people and objects at certain
times and places the moment they think
of their problems they're thinking in
the past then when they think about
their problems they feel unhappy now
their bodies in the past and if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny yeah
wow and then the emotion that's
associated is now the bodies in the past
because thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being now
here's the problem
if you can't think
greater than how you feel
and you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
you understand that feelings and
emotions are record of the past
then you're thinking in the past and
your life
will stay the same how many people
in this audience just curious believe in
the idea
that the way you think has some effect
on your life just curious
you do so you believe on some level that
your thoughts have an effect on your
life yes
so you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts
are the same thoughts as the day before
so what is the likelihood
of something happening different in your
life if ninety percent of those thoughts
conscious or unconscious are the same
thoughts as the day before
because the same thoughts will always
lead to the same choices
the same choices will lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors will create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions and those same emotions
drive your very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry
your neurochemistry your hormones and
even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think
how you act
and how you feel
and how you think
how you act and how you feel is called
your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality that's it
so then if you want to create a new
personal reality a new life
then you're gonna have to start changing
your personality how many people are
with me I hope that on some level Danica
that that at the end of my life
I feel like that I've contributed to the
world in some way I mean I mean it's not
about anything else about being a part
of change and transformation we've
already done that
well it's never ending like I'm pushing
the envelope like this yeah I don't know
what's your size your envelope like
what's the ultimate goal yeah this is
what I hope
yeah I want everybody to be empowered uh
to realize that that they actually can
make measurable changes in their life
that they're not defined by their past
that that they should they could be
defined by a vision of the future uh
that that on some level we leave a
legacy of information that shows people
really that that that that's the truth
and for me personally
um I wanted to be there on the beach
when that woman opened her eyes and
could see for the first time I wanted
her I wanted to be right there with her
and I want to celebrate that moment with
her I want to be part of that I think
there's some something innate in us as
human beings as species where we're but
we inform each other and we we we we
support each other we trust each other
we love each other you know we heal each
other we shine for each other so others
can shine I think I think that there
could be a world where we actually
actually function in a much a much
healthier way and and I think this
really is the defining time so if I
could leave
something that could change a person's
life or help them in some way I feel
really good about it for me it just is a
it's a mission that I gets me up in the
morning and I love to be I love to be
involved in and I'm nothing really
without my team and so my team is a
really great dedicated group of people
our scientific team our amazing Minds
that we're healthy Skeptics in the
beginning that now I'll do the work
because they see it as medicine they
know it's medicine they know how they've
done drug studies they know exactly what
it looks like stories and testimonials
that people have I watch them over and
over again because it changes my belief
it changes my belief and I love when
scientists run an experiment five times
in a row I love when they do that
because I know they're changing their
belief right in them they're expecting a
different result and they're getting the
same result and they're in there they're
in science to discover and they're
making a huge Discovery and it's never
been outside of the human being in the
beginning so I don't know where I'm
going to end up in in this process but
if I stay true to what I believe and
then ask keep asking greater questions I
hope we we have a really really big
breakthrough in human consciousness and
uh that would be really satisfying to me
can you share it that you used to be
concerned about folks who would
criticize you and calling your work
pseudoscience and that at a certain
point early on in your journey you would
write with the critics of mine I've
actually done that in my work too where
I can hear what people are going to say
and then so my creativity starts leaning
towards those people and then I love
that you wrote at a certain point you
were done with that I I wanted to know
if you could talk us through that
Evolution and thinking I think if you
really want to be a leader you should
study great leaders and I think all
great leaders in history are on
compromising
I just don't care for they did it for a
good effect or a bad effect they just
were uncompromising to their vision
and and when you're young and you write
your first book and you're writing that
book in your your detail then specific
about making sure you cross all your t's
and not all your eyes and your
references are all in place and you want
to go a little further
for that person who's in the back of the
room or that person who's the critic
that's going to judge your work
and I think it's a healthy place to
start because it creates a little rigor
and then I just had a lot of people that
hated me and I don't know what I ever
did to them
and and and and and I had to really sit
down with myself and say do you think
that person's ever going to like you Joe
dispenza
they're never gonna like you anyway so
forget them
there's plenty of people that do want to
hear you and then when I took my
attention off those people I started
getting happier and then we started
seeing the results that were taking
place I could care less what they said
about me I could care less I believe
that your personality creates your
personal reality
and in order to change your personal
reality your life it means then that on
some level we have to change because
nothing changes in our life unless we
change
so if people have understand that ninety
percent of the thoughts that they think
every day are the same thoughts as the
day before yeah that's that's a fact and
the same thoughts always lead to the
same choices the same choices always
lead to the same behaviors the same
behaviors create the same experiences
and the same experiences produce the
very same feelings and emotions and
those same emotions influence our very
same thoughts and our biology our
circuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones our gene expression stays the
same
because we're the same
but the repetition of firing and wiring
the same circuits in our brain in the
same way
causes us to create a very finite set of
circuitry that becomes our identity and
our personality and nerve cells that
fire together wire together which means
you keep doing it it gets easier for
them to fire and they run more
automatically
so it turns out 95 percent of Who We Are
by our midlife is a set of memorized
behaviors unconscious habits hardwired
thoughts and attitudes
conditioned emotions that are so
familiar to us that it doesn't even feel
like uh fear or it doesn't feel like
sadness is just who we are
so it usually takes crisis or trauma or
disease or diagnosis or lowest point in
your life where you're knocked to your
knees
and for that moment
you actually have a view of yourself
outside of yourself you can see yourself
from a different state the facade the
the the the the whole illusion is over
and that's when a person really begins
to think about what they've been
thinking about they begin to notice how
they speak or how they act
and I think they begin to pay attention
to those feelings uh on a more uh
regular and conscious basis and the word
meditation I look this up because when I
started my journey I'm I'm very
scientifically minded the word
meditation the symbol means to become
familiar with
so
so then the first step to change if you
wanted to create a new life you have to
change it to change your personal
reality you have to change your
personality and the first step is
consciousness or becoming aware so the
moment you become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts the moment you
become aware of your automatic reflexive
habits and and your emotional reactions
the moment you can become so conscious
of those unconscious states of mind and
body
that you don't go unconscious again so
familiar with those States and how many
times do we have to forget or go
unconscious till we no longer forget or
go unconscious and we stay conscious
that's that's that's us lighting a match
in a dark place and most people when
they do meditation they they actually
think when those voices come up and when
the chatter starts and those emotions
start
they actually think that they're doing
their meditation wrong
and I want them to know that they're
actually doing it right because you're
coming up against those thoughts that
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by many people uh you all of a
sudden catch how you speak and people
say if I really want to be happy let's
think about this
I don't wanna I don't want to complain I
don't want to blame I don't want to make
excuses I don't want to feel sorry for
myself I'm going to stop that now that's
breaking a habit of being yourself
that's a that takes a lot of energy and
a lot of awareness and and and our
environment then the circumstances our
environments are always available for us
to think and feel equal to everything in
our life you know so the environment for
many people as we said earlier controls
the way they think and feel so when they
respond to their co-worker when they
respond to the news when they respond to
the
um the the traffic in their life
that response causes them to return back
to those unconscious programs so but
sitting in a meditation and really
sitting in the fire and
believing that there's something on the
other side of that thought
other side of some Behavior or some
emotion that feels makes us feel a
certain way that's that's stepping into
the unknown and and it takes
um
it takes us disconnecting from the
environment that's what meditation is
about playing music or hearing nothing
or closing your eyes and not eating not
smelling not tasting not feeling with
your body you're putting your body away
and you're not letting it be the mind or
the program you're making it sit still
you're training the animal right and and
a person starts feeling emotional and
they catch themselves
starting to feel those emotions instead
of letting that emotion drive a certain
thoughts or actions
that person settles the body down
in the meditation and brings it back
into the present moment and that's a
victory well I think that uh if you look
at just the scientific model of how we
are structured that by the time we're 35
years old we've done so many things
so many times that it becomes an
unconscious habit and 95 percent of who
we are is really unconscious thoughts uh
automatic habits emotional reactions
beliefs perceptions attitudes that
function pretty much behind the scenes
of our awareness
so the process of becoming conscious
of what you're unconscious about
yourself begins the process of change
so how you think how you act and how you
feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality that's it
so if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
you'd have to change your personality
which means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and changing
become aware of your automatic habits
and behaviors and modify them
and then look at the emotions that
you've experienced that keep you
anchored to the past and really look at
them and decide do these emotions really
belong in my future
so when you begin to think differently
when you begin to act differently you
begin to feel differently your life is
going to change
so most people
like to wait for
a reason to change like a crisis or a
trauma or a diagnosis from some disease
now all of a sudden they realize that
they can't go on living the same life
any longer they have to change something
about themselves
so I think that my message is why wait
for that trauma that when you teach
people
that they can begin to create a better
life for themselves and even improve
their health
and give them the tools on how to do it
it becomes more uh effective for
everybody you know here's the key
is that we are already wired to do this
we're always always in the process of
creation if we're truly relaxed and
beginning to think about what we want
for ourselves in our lives
when we're living in stress and we're
living in survival then it's not a time
to create so getting people out of those
survival States into more creative
States allows them to do it we're
innately wired to do what
reality that reality that hasn't changed
no matter what you did you tried you
forced you prayed you hoped you wished
you hired people you fired people you've
forgiven you've done all those things
and still it hasn't changed that's
because the moment you come back to your
senses you're consciously or
unconsciously having certain thoughts
that are connected to that problem that
are producing a certain frequency or a
certain feeling and you're producing the
same energy every single day and your
life stays the same are you with me
still think about this
think about that problem in your life or
that condition is that has never changed
what are your thoughts about it
it's not something pleasant is it
and what are the feelings associated
with it there aren't feelings that you
don't typically want to live by but you
live by those feelings every single day
yes or no
so then you're reacting consciously or
unconsciously to the thought of the
problem or the actual problem over and
over again you are broadcasting the
electromagnetic signature into your
field but if you're creating and those
thoughts are these lower frequency
thoughts then you have very little
effect on matter so now you got to go
make the problem happy you gotta go
change it with you you got to get your
identity or personality involved in it
are you with me still come on
so then we found out
in the research that we've done and we
now know there's a formula
that when a person takes all of their
attention off their body
all of their attention off the people in
their life all their attention off their
things they own their cell phone their
computer their car every object or
material thing take their attention off
their home where they sleep where they
work they take all the attention off
where they're even sitting and they take
their attention off the predictable
future or their familiar past and they
find The Sweet Spot of the generous
present moment then they're disinvesting
all of their attention and energy out of
this three-dimensional reality and
they're moving in the opposite direction
towards the unified field
and now when they become nobody no one
no thing nowhere and no time they have
to pass through
different layers of emotions that are
have memories different frequencies that
are carrying different that's carrying
different information and they gotta
pass through these layers that have
become their identity and most people
don't know how to make their way through
so they do a little bit and then they
come back to their identity the same
personality most of you almost all of
you have traversed through these
frequencies and reached the point where
you can become nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and that is the
moment you are pure Consciousness and
you now are no longer associating with
anything in three-dimensional reality
and if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you're
disinvesting all of your attention and
energy out of this three-dimensional
reality off of everything that's known
and you're making a choice to go to a
field where all possibilities exist the
unknown the quantum field there's tiny
little calcium carbonate crystals in the
pineal gland that are stacked among top
of each other and the human being
rhombohedrons
and they're stacked up on top of each
other and the research says
that it has piezoelectric properties
what does that mean I looked it up
when you apply a mechanical stress
to these crystals the mechanical stress
begins to create an electrical charge in
the crystal
and the compression begins to polarize
the ends of the crystal with a positive
charge and a negative charge and when
you polarize the crystal with a positive
charge and a negative charge what do you
have
a magnet
and all of a sudden as you compress
those crystals the mechanical stress
creates an electrical field
and that field actually expands until
the crystals can't stretch any longer
and then the field reverses
and when the field reverses the field
actually exerts a pressure against the
crystals again
that causes the crystals to expand and
the next thing you know you have a
little radio receiver
how many people understand
and you switch on the brain's radio
receiver
and now the brain can tune in
the frequencies
beyond the senses
and that is the mystical gland
and the research says it's a transducer
how do I know
I looked it up
I didn't go on social I looked it up
transducer like a television antenna
that's what it said
taking energy and information in one
form and turning it into pictures and
images meaning
and that's why it's called the third eye
because you have an inner Vision that's
more real than the outer world the brain
now is picking up information from the
field and it's transducing it into
profound imagery a mystical
transcendental moment and we do the
breath
when you finish that breath I'm going to
ask you to finish it right on that
pineal gland that's your target
and I'm going to ask you to hold your
breath
now this is not torture
I'm not asking you to hold your breath
to see how long you can hold your breath
if you're thinking about how long you're
holding your breath you're not doing it
I want your attention as you hold your
breath I'm going to ask you to lift this
up pull this in lock this down
straighten your spine drop down and pump
and squeeze a little bit more and I just
want you to keep squeezing and pushing
that fluid right up against that Target
there or
I'll say Exile and then you feel and we
go get it again
I don't feel like it is not going to do
anything
I'm too old nothing will happen you got
to leave that behind you you got to get
lost in the act
and when that energy moves I have had it
happen
thousands of times
it is big
it's not like oh I'm an energy worker
it's not like that
it's like holy heck
it's a train that's moving
and it goes right up to the brain
and that energy is being released in the
brain and the Brain goes into those
gamma brainwave patterns very high gamma
brainwave patterns your personality
creates your personal reality that's it
and your personality is made of how you
think
how you act and how you feel so if you
keep thinking the same way you keep
acting the same way you keep feeling the
same way everything stays the same in
your life because nothing changes in
your life until you change right so
turns out if you keep thinking the same
way making the same choices doing the
same things creating the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions or responding to your life in
the exact same way
you keep doing that your biology tends
to get more rigid we fire and wire the
same circuits we hardwire our brain and
they it only takes a small stimulation
or small fodder a response to someone or
something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically
so
so your biology your neurochemistry your
your hormones your genes everything
stays the same because you're the same
so crisis and Trauma is always the thing
that gets a person to really start
looking at how do I really change right
so so we want to tell people let's not
wait for that let's let's learn and
change in a state of growth and
inspiration so
so if you keep doing those same things
over and over again the middle life
period we we become very very
programmable
so in order for us to change we have to
become conscious of how we think we have
to become really aware of how we behave
what our habits are even how we speak
now this is a tough one we have to
really look at the emotions that we live
by every single day and and say wow this
this actually could be unworthiness this
could actually be guilt but if you're
too busy with your cell phone and your
social media and you're too busy with
your kids and running around and the
most your environment can distract you
from these feelings so
my interest is to get people to retreat
from their lives right just for
five seven days and and remove the
constant stimulation in their external
environment that reminds them of who
they think they are as a personality
to separate themselves from the people
they know and the places they go and the
things they do at the exact same time
and then fill their brain with knowledge
and information and then remind them
that they're actually creating their
life
so if your personality creates your
personal reality and that means that if
in order for you to change your personal
reality you got to change your
personality how would an abundant person
think write it down dude and fire and
why are those thoughts in your brain and
install the hardware keep doing it with
attention and intention it becomes the
new voice in your head it becomes a
software program then say okay
how am I going to be in my life today
what would an abundant person how would
they behave and before you reach for
your cell phone start scrolling through
your social media close your eyes and
rehearse in your mind how that person
would walk how they would Breathe how
they would smile how they would greet
people how they would be on Zoom calls
how would they be in traffic how would
they be at dinner
and and the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing the ACT if you're
truly present
the brain does not know the difference
between the real life experience and
what you're imagining in fact just a
little bit of time you start to install
the neurological Hardware to look like
you already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it's primed
for the future keep doing it keep
rehearsing no different than playing an
instrument no different than learning
how to dance no different on learning
how to act or play a sport everybody's
always rehearsing right the rehearsal
process
changes the brain to look like you've
already done it you've already
experienced it now what's the essential
part of that the hardware is in place
now all you gotta do is step into the
footprint keep doing it it becomes a
software program you start acting like
an abundant person everything changes
your energy changes your mood changes
the way you walk the way you breathe
your posture changes you're out of the
known right you've got to condition the
body now emotionally into the future
can't open your eyes in the morning
until you are feeling worthy to receive
and if you can't feel worthy to receive
then if not now when if it takes you two
hours to get there ask me if it's worth
30 years
of running trying to get what you need
matter to matter
okay so then the person who wrestles
with their lack they're out of the
bleachers
and they're on the playing field but
here's what we learned here's what we
learned let's go back to beliefs now so
remember belief is just the thought you
keep thinking over and over again a
belief is something that you keep
thinking enough times that you hardwired
in your brain and it becomes an
automatic program and we have beliefs
about all kinds of things money
relationships God whatever it is it's
all based on what we've been told or our
past experiences right
the boundaries of those beliefs are our
emotions right so let's just say you got
betrayed or somebody abused you or your
father told you that money was bad and
there's never enough of it or whatever
that's a story okay but but somehow it
left an impression on you remember that
event very clearly and that's kind of
rooted in who you are right
okay so that emotion then is the
boundary of our belief Okay so
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being if you take a
thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling a thought and a feeling of
thought and a feeling it's called an
attitude yes there's a good thoughts
with a series of Good Feelings you say I
have a good attitude today you have a
series of negative thoughts that are
connected to a series of negative
feelings you say have a bad attitude
today so attitudes are just shortened
states of being good attitude in the
morning bad attitude in the afternoon if
you take an attitude and attitude
imagine you keep those up any string
attitudes together you create what's
called a belief and a belief is just an
extended state of being so if you keep
thinking the same thought you keep
hardwiring in the brain you keep feeling
the same feeling you keep conditioning
in your body the redundancy of that
cycle over and over again conditions the
body to subconsciously become the mind
of that belief and all beliefs
or subconscious states of being okay
take a belief a belief a belief in your
string them together you form what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this how many
things
you could get done if you had an
infinite amount of time
and if a number of possibilities that's
the quantum now in the quantum there's
nothing structural there's nothing
material there's nothing physical
there's no form right so what is it made
of it's made of energy frequency
vibration
thought Consciousness information and
every thought in that realm has a
frequency so all possibilities already
exist you don't have to create the
possibility in fact all you have to do
is become aware that exists
the moment you do that you you are
changing the thought and you're
producing a different frequency now if
the person is astute enough to feel the
frequency of the thought in the quantum
and not wait for the experience to
happen but the thought of abundance
would produce the feeling of abundance
for most people in three-dimensional
reality the thought of abundance
produces the lack of not having it
that's why they're trying to create it
right but in the quantum you got to feel
it in order to experience it okay so as
you get closer and closer to that point
that source that Singularity pure love
the zero point field whatever you want
to call it a universal mind that the
Creator pure Consciousness as you get
closer and closer to it
the closer you get to it the more bliss
the more love the more the more
um
ecstasy you feel uh then you're not no
longer creating from lack or Separation
The Closer you get to it in the process
of creation the shorter the distance
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of having it between the
cause and the effect from one point of
Consciousness and the other point of
Consciousness so then people can create
from the field instead of from matter
if they have a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and they actually can
send the coherent signal out and feel
the emotion ahead of the experience then
those synchronicities and opportunities
that they're creating from fifth
dimensional reality requires doing less
somehow it's drawn to us or it comes to
us it comes in ways that we least expect
that surprises us like whoa where did
that come from and now what does that do
it proves to you that you're the creator
of your life that instead of the victim
of your life and what's a victim
you say to someone why are you feeling
this way what's wrong with you today and
they say I am this way
because of that person because of that
circumstance what they're really saying
is that person or circumstances actually
controlling my feelings and controlling
my thoughts well anything that's
controlling my feelings and my thoughts
I'm victim to right so yeah it makes
sense then that when things are good you
feel good when things are bad you feel
bad right so so when you start changing
the way you think and feeling it starts
producing outcomes in your life you're
going to believe you're more you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life and the hardest part
about all of this is just making the
time to do it what is healing for you
I think people come to our work Florence
for all kinds of reasons they they come
to heal
they come to find love
uh they come to or to get beyond their
traumas of the past they come for a
mystical experience they come for wealth
or abundance
um but really I think when people really
come for as wholeness
and and and when you see brain and heart
coherence this this this Union of the
two of the of the heart and the mind or
the heart and the Brain
um there is a sense of wholeness there
is a sense of healing and
I think if you heal your heart
you heal your mind
I think you heal your mind do you you
heal your heart
and when people finally Break Free
from those chains of the emotions that
they lived by on a daily basis when they
break free of their habituations even in
the way they speak when they overcome
their hard-wired beliefs that they've
thought over and over again until they
accepted him without without any
analysis
when they overcome that programming to a
certain degree
they that wholeness that they feel
is uh the healing in and of itself
they're not waiting for their healing or
their health to change so they could
feel gratitude so they could feel whole
they actually understand that when they
feel gratitude and they still feel
homeless that's when their Healing
Begins so then anything that causes us
to move out of that state
within us
a reaction or response from someone or
something in our life that would move us
from that state of grace
I promise you if you're truly in the
river of change and you wanted to heal
you would think about how you would
respond differently
to that person or circumstance the next
time so you wouldn't lose that feeling
because you would actually no longer be
signaling the same genes in the same way
the moment you felt familiar emotions
you would be signaling old genes and so
the person who understands the what
in what they're doing and the why that
if I live by this emotional state every
single day if the environment signals
the gene okay
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion if I live by
this emotion I could signal genes ahead
of my environment and I could actually
change my health
now this is when meditation no longer
becomes a have to
this is now when meditation becomes very
practical because the person is going to
rehearse in their mind how they are
going to think in their day what they
are going to believe and they're going
to repeat it enough times and a belief
is just the thought you keep thinking
over and over again until it becomes
hardwired in your brain they're going to
review that belief and they're going to
keep firing and wiring it they're going
to change the way they respond to their
co-worker to their spouse to their to
their boss to the news they're going to
change their response and they're going
to rehearse it in their mind the mental
rehearsal as you know changes the brain
to look like it's already happened
they're going to say I gotta feel this
feeling
if it takes me a hundred times today
to feel this feeling I'm going to bring
it up a hundred times over and over
again so I get so good at feeling it I
can bring it up whenever I want
and stop from default right and then
when people do that that that the
overcoming process is the becoming
process that so many people have healed
in this work
and they didn't even realize that when
they were sitting and their body was
raging and out of balance and they were
working with settling it down and
overcoming those survival emotions
overcoming those programs those
habituations that that overcoming
process was actually the becoming
process so many people when they
actually got to the point where they
were so happy with themselves
so in love with themselves so in love
with life so grateful for being like
they could care less
if they had their health condition they
no longer identified with it any longer
that was the moment it went away and you
ask that person where where is the the
the disease they'll tell you it's in the
old person they healed themselves by
changing themselves they they're happy
with themselves now they don't want to
be anybody else as I read your books
walking down the path of what's actually
happening inside your body when you're
having these healing moments where
you're healing yourself inside or you're
having these Transitions and
experiencing a negative thought or a
negative emotional feeling inside your
body
um can you give people something to
latch onto that allows them to
understand what that's supposed to feel
like and then how how obviously to walk
down the path to changing it look I mean
you have to think about this I mean the
fact that you can think about what
you're thinking about
makes you wonder who's doing the
observing of those thoughts right the
fact that you can be aware of what
you're thinking means you're not the
thought you're the executor or the
controller of that thought you're the
Consciousness that's executing that
thought so most people think well just
because I have a thought it's true
that's not true just because you have a
thought doesn't necessarily mean it's
true emotions and feelings are a record
of the past
so if you're feeling the familiar
emotions every single day of unhappiness
or unworthiness or insecurity then
you're starting your day from the past
and if those emotions are driving your
thoughts and you can't think greater
than how you feel then you're thinking
in the past and for the most part your
day is going to stay the same so the
first step
without a doubt and is getting people
the right information the more knowledge
you have in understanding how you work
and how your brain and body works in a
simple way the better you have the
operating manual to take care of
yourself I have a question regarding the
use of cell phones and how it generates
dopamine
and how is it in some way affects our
meditations or ability to meditate
excellent question
the question was to repeat it I want to
know the effects of cell phones
on our brains and how it affects our
dopamine levels and and you know I I
raised three kids and
you know kids use technology and I was
saying this when I was talking to some
of you this morning over a cup of coffee
that that if your children are using
cell phones for information basically we
are information that's all we are
and they're they're they're accessing
information the way they do and they're
using their cell phones in all kinds of
ways for stimulation
there should be a period of time where
they were able to set it down just like
for you
and if you can't break your romance with
your cell phone
then it owns you would you agree
because that's what keeps you connected
to networks socially that kind of social
Consciousness is is is is is is
maintained through networks and
it feeds us because we love tribe We
Love Culture we love connection but it's
it's got to be done with discernment
so what happens for people is
if they they can't break from it and go
from a narrow Focus to a broad Focus
like get out in nature go hike go get on
a boat I mean open your focus and look
at the sunset you don't think that
creates Alpha in your brain it does
nature does that the resonance the
human's constant is the exact 7.8
frequency of alpha brain waves and
training us
to connection
so when when they've done the research
on on cell phones the video gaming to
start with they said to these kids Hey
listen um here's how it's going to go
you guys want to make some money what do
you think the kids said yeah let's make
some money yeah I said okay we're gonna
get you involved in the video game
and then we're going to ring a bell
and you have five seconds to stop if you
stop in five seconds we'll give you a
dollar and we're just gonna go as long
as you remember how long it went do you
know that none of the children none of
them were able to stop
that's how that's how addictive it is
so the research shows then
that when you begin to blow somebody up
or you shoot someone or you get a text
you know that's important text to you
there's a release of dopamine in your
brain the pleasure chemical reward
chemical is released but if you're
overdoing it and you're playing a lot of
video gaming and you're blowing
something something up or blowing
someone up or breaking through some
level or doing something the reward
systems are being activated in your
brain and you start releasing too much
dopamine all at once
and that burst of dopamine into the
brain is more than the receptor sites
have to handle it you understand what
I'm saying come on
so then the over amount of dopamine is
not being absorbed by those receptors
receptors close down it's too much they
become desensitized it's like living
with a spouse that always yells at you
they got to yell a little louder to get
your attention the next time you need a
little bit more now to turn it on the
next time does that make sense
so then the pleasure cam the pleasure
centers start recalibrating to a higher
and higher level it takes more now to
turn the money I do a bigger burst to
get them stimulated
are you with me still
so the pleasure centers start
recalibrating to such a high level that
now the person needs the game
needs the phone to feel something
to make that feeling because in the
absence of any stimulation
they experience a loss of pleasure
you understand what I'm saying
they become desensitized to pleasure so
a walk with your dog
go tell a kid to go see their
grandmother
watch a sunset just way too slow
they're over stimulated are you with me
still and that's called adhedonia you
can't find pleasure from anything
at hedonia for all my listeners what's
step one so we're not going to take them
from
a very egocentric and
physically oriented to the end mystical
Journey overnight but what's step one
that you suggested and recommend that
everyone gets on tomorrow when they wake
up
look I mean it's really simple I don't
have a problem with you
putting your attention on your body I
think you should I think you should
really take care of your temple and make
sure that you treat it really well but
there's a time when you have to get
Beyond it and if you can't be on get
Beyond it then um that that's your
identity so so I think that people come
to this work for many different reasons
some people come for health conditions
or diseases people come because they
want a new life people come because they
want answers but I don't really care
what a person comes for because
ultimately when they start connecting
their values change and they start
feeling differently and they change and
and they still have a great body and
they still have a healthy body but in
addition to that they have a healthy
mind and and so um I think really a
great start for people is to wake up in
the morning and ask themselves a simple
question what is the greatest ideal of
myself that I can be today what is the
greatest expression of myself and really
sit down
and decide who they want to be when they
open their eyes and just the act of
closing your eyes and thinking about it
and making choices differently than you
typically do and and rehearsing them and
actually follow through and doing them
is going to lead you to A Whole New Life
over time so it's not that mystical
because the mystical is the side effect
it's the phenomenon of this work the the
real thing is to to have a a more
profoundly enriched life where you're in
it and you love it and you want more of
it that's uh that's what I want for
everybody and for some people it may be
the mystical for some people it may be a
million dollars or ten million dollars I
don't care I just want them to create it
just whatever you want just get busy
creating it and prove to yourself really
how powerful you are and and um we've
got a lot of people doing it and in beta
brainwave patterns you tend to pay more
attention to your outer world that's
healthy
so then when you're aroused though by
the hormones of stress now you move into
that high beta brainwave pattern and now
you're overly analytical
in fact you're trying to figure things
out
and when you're when you're aroused by
those stress hormones and the emotions
of those hormones are a record of the
past our research shows that when you're
analyzing some problem
some condition something about yourself
within that emotion you're making your
brain worse because you're driving it
further into higher beta brainwave
patterns because as you think about the
problem you start producing more of the
chemistry and you start analyzing and
all of a sudden you get caught in this
Loop how many people understand and
people stay stuck
for many many many years in that high
beta brainwave pattern and now the
Reliant on something outside of them to
change that state whether it's a drug a
drink whatever it is a computer game
something to help them to to change
their internal State the whole purpose
of meditation is to get beyond the
analytical mind and what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is the analytical mind and so we'll
talk about that in a minute but we teach
people how to create coherent brains and
of course we also teach them and they
understand that when they're resentful
or they're impatient or they're
frustrated their heart also beats
incoherently as well so then is it
possible then to train them to regulate
their autonomic nervous system by
changing their brain waves and by
changing their heart coherence so then
they can begin to transform themselves
and transform matter and that's kind of
the model that we use next slide quick
little overview on brain waves here look
at the top one there it says beta brain
waves you can see they're pretty fast
your brain's job is to create meaning or
coherence between what's going on in
your outer world and what's going on in
your inner world most people function in
beta brainwave patterns when they're
awake and they wake up in their morning
and their brain starts making serotonin
they start to use their senses and
they're integrating everything through
their senses and their brains trying to
process all that information into
meaning so they're sitting there feeling
pain they're tired they're hungry they
have the light on they're doing a few
things and the brain's got to deal with
all that information so brain waves in
the thinking brain are pretty quick when
you close your eyes and you eliminate
your external environment as an example
your brain kind of slows down in brain
waves because it's processing less
information so now you're in Alpha and
Alpha instead of the outer World being
more real the inner world starts
becoming more real when your body falls
asleep and your mind is awake you move
into what's called Theta brainwave
patterns that's a good place to be
because if you've conditioned your body
to be the mind then your body's asleep
and your mind is awake that means it's
no longer the mind then you can fall
right into some pretty quick changes is
and reprogram those automatic programs
Delta of course is restorative sleep and
we won't have time to get into gamma but
I call gamma super Consciousness or
super awareness that's when the brain is
aroused but instead of because of some
predator or some threat in the
environment the brain is aroused because
the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and it's releasing energy
instead of out of the body up into the
brain and the person's really has all
their attention on the inner experience
I'm curious uh why is it that as humans
we default to this fear-based thinking
it's so hard wired in us as a species
that's lived in survival for
for so many thousands of years and in
survival you know fear is really
adaptive if you want to survive that
chemical Rush is telling you that
there's danger or there's a threat and
to run from that danger or stay off and
face the conflict you know that was kind
of the model of of survival of the
fittest so when we perceive the problems
and challenges in our life and it evokes
fear right like and because we don't
think we can control it or we can't
predict it or it looks like things could
get worse that's what turns on that
primitive nervous system that puts you
in a state of alarm in a state of
arousal and we're just been bred for
thousands of years to to live in
survival and turns out that when we we
live in those States for extended
periods of time it has biological felt
effects on the health of the body but
but to the person the arousal then
becomes something stimulating
so without knowing it they they start
relying on the response to stimulate
their body to keep it awake to keep it
alive and then they can think about
their problems in the same exact way and
produce that arousal and keep the body
in a state of a you know state of
emergency
turns out it gets a little addictive
after a while and and then we start
using the people and problems in our
life to reaffirm that addiction to that
emotion and we're addicted to a a life a
miserable life we don't even like you
know and that's why change becomes so
hard because that becomes the known that
becomes the familiar and you're always
you know anticipating the next moment
but that's a default it's hardwired in
the human being because survival was
adaptive at one point but fast forward
to now and and the conditions and are no
longer T-Rex chasing you they're just a
little bit more complex and it requires
a lot of uncertainty and a lot of
unpredictability and that's exactly what
creates the hormones of stress so our
response to the environment has to
change and that's what we practice doing
because when you're no longer responding
to the same conditions in the same
emotional way I think when you master
your emotions you master your Creations
things start to change in your life the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you pay attention to the person or the
problem that's our Vital life force
we're giving to that person or that
problem well and then we're telling the
story 50 different times to all of our
friends can you believe this
reaffirming reaffirming the same feeling
over and over again and the body's
actually moving out of balance more and
more every time we do that there we're
actually draining the body from energy
right so so it makes sense then that
when people do this a long time then
they they can't feel anything else but
anger fear pain suffering guilt shame
anxiety competition Envy jealousy and
security resentment those are all
derived from the hormones of stress you
know and and psychology calls those
normal human States Of Consciousness
those are Altered States of
consciousness
so so it makes sense then that if those
emotions make us feel one way because
the body is always out of balance we
decided to do an experiment we took 117
people and we said listen
we want you to stop feeling those
emotions just for three times a day for
15 minutes we're just going to practice
feeling a different emotion yeah I know
but I can't feel that I know I know you
can't feel it now because you're really
good at feeling that other stuff but if
we work with you just work with us turns
out
10-15 minutes of gratitude two or three
times a day
their immune system strengthened by 50
percent they they made the most robust
immunoglobulin you know immunoglobulin a
which is the primary defense against
bacteria and viruses the body's getting
a boost there's an internal Army now and
it turns out that when that occurs a lot
of pain inflammation goes away and a lot
of immune mediated conditions from
cancer all the way to food allergies and
everything in between so so we found out
that your thoughts could actually make
you well I'll spend a month of my own
personal journey in practicing surrender
like what is surrender how much more
surrender could I surrender in my life
in my meditations I'll work on that you
know for a period of time I'll work on
other times laying down after a
meditation and keep working on relaxing
my body more and more while I work on
staying awake because I think that's the
door right so I'll practice that for a
period of time so that when I get back
into my work
uh in my regular meditations those
things are enhanced right and the breath
is another thing that you can practice
as part of your whole meditation
practice
that we get good at whatever we practice
right I mean that's just the way it is
so so I just wanted that to be a
contribution
uh to the community for those people who
want to improve their skill
of doing the breath so let's say that
they practice that and they okay this
time every day before I go to bed even
though I'm tired I'm going to practice
this thing so that in my morning
meditations my breath becomes more more
enhanced or more enriched and so
um it's just something you can as a tool
you can take and and put into your
practice so
um I try to So when you say do a
meditation that has the breath in it
along with other things in that
meditation you'll be more proficient at
doing the breath instead of resisting it
you'll actually enjoy it and we have
people you know we can ask them to do
the breath we can have their brain
hooked up and we they I can tell you I
can say to that person would you go into
high gamma for the scientists and they
can do it in five minutes because why
they practice it enough times that
they're good at it from my last five
years of traveling around the world the
common people that look just like you
were doing the uncommon
they're healing themselves of very
serious health conditions
they're creating better opportunities
and better lives for themselves new
careers they're healing old scars and
wounds that kept them connected to the
Past
and they're having mystical experiences
that transcend language that take them
years to be able to understand and
explain
and they look just like you
that most people in their life wait for
that crisis or the trauma the disease
the diagnosis some kind of loss betrayal
in their life before they make up their
mind to change
and my message has always been why wait
why wait for that tragedy before you
decide to change who you are
that when you begin to apply these
principles because you understand that
they work
then it means then you'll believe in a
future more than you believe in your
past
and people who do the work are more in
love with the future than they are with
their past
and they're more interested in telling
the story of possibility in their future
than reliving the emotions and
experiences of past to change is to be
greater than your environment that means
be greater than the conditions in your
life to be greater than the
circumstances in your world and every
great person in history knew this that
means you have to be defined by a vision
in the future instead of the memories of
the past to change means be greater than
your body those unconscious habits and
behaviors and choices that you've made
over and over again so many times that
the body becomes the Mind emotions that
are connected to past experiences keep
you anchored emotionally to the past and
if those emotions are driving your
thoughts and those thoughts are creating
the same emotions then your body has
become the mind which means that in
order for you to change you're going to
have to get greater than those emotional
reactions habits and hardwired attitudes
that keep you running unconscious
programs and to change then is to be
greater than time if you're waking up
every single day and making the same
choices and demonstrating the same
behaviors and creating the same
experiences and you do that over and
over again it makes sense that your past
is going to look a lot like your future
and your future will be more of your
past finding The Sweet Spot of the
generous present moment existing in that
place where you're no longer trying to
predict the future based on the past
means you're in the unknown and when
you're in that place called The Eternal
present moment that's where all
possibilities exist give it a try let's
just say that lack is ingrained in there
you got the story you lived on the
streets you lost everything you got
betrayed your business partner took
everything took your wife took you got
the story in the half okay okay you got
to start telling the new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
the future right okay so in order for us
to change a belief or perception about
ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
condition in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you've got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created with them
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to the mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
you're impossible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
exactly big explosion on the quantum
field big explosion so the side effect
of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack or lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
and that's 95 percent of who we are
right yes so then
the side effect of the beginning of this
process
is a lot of discomfort it is a lot of
discomfort because you're stepping
outside the known into the unknown and
now you can't predict it's scary no no
you'd rather hold on to your lack the
pain and suffering rather tell the story
of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
about who you become
so the overcoming process becomes the
becoming process and so many people
come to this work they want abundance
they want healing they want a new
relationship they want a new career they
want the mystical but really they want
wholeness and and the one healing they
want peace they want wholeness because
they feel on whole well well when you're
in lack or you're in separation you're
not home imagine feeling so much
wholeness that's impossible to want
that's what our that's what we're
working on with people then you can
really enjoy a sunset then you can
really enjoy a meal and you can really
enjoy your friends you can I I I
talk to people that are very abundant I
mean in the billions abundant and you
know
so many of them say we are in misery
because in our whole we're in agony
because they can enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want wherever they want that's
Freedom right or people want to
abundance the sponsoring thought is
really they want freedom right or
whatever their sponsoring thought would
be the amount of emotion
that comes with the thought because
every time you have a thought you make a
chemical right if you have a good
thought and make you have a chemical
that makes you feel good you have an
arousing thought that causes you to feel
angry
short term that's okay but
the long-term effects of that keeps
knocking the brain and body out of
balance so
when we turn on that primitive nervous
system called the fight-or-flight
nervous system we're mobilizing enormous
amounts of energy in our body's
resources that we would typically use
for healing digestion reproduction
whatever assimilation we're robbing
those systems and we're saying there's a
threat there's a danger there's
something really really that needs all
of your attention in your outer
environment and that that arousal causes
us to feel fear or any derivative
derivative of it aggression or anger or
pain so
when we respond to the environment like
that our bodies knocked out of balance
because we're mobilizing all that energy
pupils dilate respiratory rate goes up
heart rate goes off up digestive juices
shut down blood is sent to the
extremities of the body is ready to run
fight or hide
all organisms in nature can tolerate
that short term
if you turn on that stress response and
you can't turn it off now you're headed
for disease because no organism can live
an emergency mode without a moment for
for regeneration or growth and repair
all right so the arousal for some reason
feels good to human beings
and that arousal gives us a rush of
energy and then we need the bad news we
need the problems in our life we need
the poor relationship we need whatever
it is
to cause us to feel this kind of arousal
and because we're addicted to it will we
become addicted to the life we don't
even like so then that's the biggest aha
moment and it's like you actually become
addicted to the life you don't want
right so then so take it a step further
then when you think about that life
you produce the same chemistry in your
brain and body in the same exact way as
if you were actually re-experiencing it
so now the thought
is turning on the stress response
and it's a scientific fact that the
long-term effects of the hormones of
stress push the genetic buttons and
create disease well if you can turn on
that stress response just by thought
alone
then your thoughts could make you sick
so because you're knocking your brain
and body out of balance over and over
again and depleting your body's
resources that you could be used using
for healing and it just turns out the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you pay attention to the person or the
problem and that's our Vital life force
we're giving to that person or that
problem is it possible then if your
thoughts can make you sick your thoughts
could make you well
and that's exactly what our research
shows that you keep thinking the same
way you keep making the same choices you
keep doing the same things you keep
having the same experiences and reacting
to the same conditions with the same
emotions
for the most part your genes and your
brain and everything is going to stay
the same and your blood values because
you're the same so then the process of
thinking differently making different
choices doing different things creating
different experiences and feeling
different emotions if you do that for
seven days
you have significant changes that take
place on a cellular level on your brain
in in just about every part of your
biology because you're you're you're
making those changes our discoveries
really have to do with
showing people that their nervous system
is the greatest Pharmacy in the world
that it that it makes chemicals that
work better than any drug we can say
that with with such certainty when a
person moves into into these states
the Practical part of it all the time is
is the daily practice people in our work
that do this work they do it really
because they understand what they're
doing and why they're doing it and when
you combine the what and the why the how
it tends to get easier I love what you
said about the nervous system being sort
of the greatest Pharmacy because I don't
think we know the power of our bodies
the power of our health the power of
coherence yeah well that's a great
question because the people who live in
stress are living in survival as they
try to control and predict everything
that takes place in their life every
person every object every circumstance
has a neurological Network in the brain
and the arousal of the stress hormones
shifts our attention very quickly to all
these elements in our lives and our
brains literally start firing out of
order they start firing like a lightning
storm and the clouds very incoherently
and networks of neurons start working
separately from one another they come
departmentalized when the brain is
incoherent we're incoherent when the
brain isn't working right we're not
working right the heart which is now
pumping an enormous amount of blood
against a closed system the the arteries
aren't you're not running you're not
fighting so the pressure against the
heart causes the heart to be very
incoherently and in that state energy
goes down in the heart incoherence
creates a loss of energy both in the
heart and the brain so that kind of
dysregulation that takes place in the
nervous system
begins to send very incoherent messages
through the autonomic nervous system to
all the cells and tissues and organs in
the body and the brain is now really
over focused you know when you're in
stress you're really thinking a lot
you're thinking about the same thing
over and over again it's looping and
that looping actually within that
emotional state is actually driving your
brain to become more and more analytical
and moving into very high brainwave
States you're narrowing your focus on
something and that's what we do when the
arousal of stress causes us to pinpoint
our focus on a personal circumstance on
a problem a thought whatever it is that
that cycle then is continuously causing
the body to move out of balance just
because the brain and the heart are
sending signals to the body that are
that the cells don't understand it's not
coherent that's autonomic dysregulation
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being
and you're thinking the same thoughts
that are creating the same feelings and
same emotions and those emotions are
influencing your thoughts would you
agree then you're signaling that same
gene over and over again and if genes
are responsible for the structure and
the function of the body and you keep
selecting and instructing the same gene
you're going to wear that Gene out yes
or no just like gears in your car
picking the facts of a facts of a facts
of a fax or a copy of a copy of a copy
sooner or later it's going to lose its
detail yes or no and that's exactly what
happens to the body the body begins to
break down because those proteins are
responsible for your physiology for your
structure
so then if immune cells make immune
proteins
and you're living in fear every single
day
you're living in anger and resentment
and impatience every single day then
you're signaling the same gene in the
same way yes or no and if you keep doing
that for a period of time sooner or
later you're going to program that Gene
and all of a sudden the body is going to
get unhealthy yes or no
and look you know people say well I did
my meditation
three days and nothing happened
but I tell them how long did it take you
to create that condition tell me
so then if meditation means to become
familiar with
you got to become more familiar with the
thoughts behaviors and emotions of your
future then familiar with the thoughts
and behaviors emotions of your past yes
or no
so then if you keep firing and wiring
the same circuits in your brain
installing the circuits the hardware
becomes a software program and it gets
easier to think in unlimited ways it
gets easier to act like a wealthy person
it becomes easier than to cultivate the
emotions of your future instead of the
emotions of your past most of us tell
the story of our past in a negative
Sense on how it's held us back
um
millions of times of our life as opposed
to the story of the future of what we
want to create or who we want to become
yeah listen again you tell that story in
the latest research on memory says that
memory is creative that in fact fifty
percent of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
and it's less of the truth because you
got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and they
were right you know they were
helicopters snowstorms didn't matter if
he was firing bullets the worst thing
you could possibly imagine and then
you've got to feel that emotion right
and then you look at this oh yeah it
must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity
the more you hold on to that identity of
the past the harder it is to become who
you want to be in the future well here's
here's to answer the other part of your
question when we started talking
how do you get that person out of their
past yeah well we need a week it's not
gonna happen if it doesn't happen
overnight no I want them to come right
up against their fear I want them to
come right up against their doubt I want
them to come up against the point where
they're going to give up and quit and
they're going to sit there and nobody
else is giving up and quitting and
they're going to go all in more and
they're going to start believing what
there's something on the other side of
that emotion they're going to believe
that there's something past the story of
their past because they're stretching
themselves out of the known and it takes
a tremendous amount of awareness
repetition information model building
sharing understanding experiencing to
finally have a person get to the point
where they just let go and when they do
the body's liberated from the past and
there's a release of energy and we now
know that there's a formula to teach
people how to do that in fact we're
getting so good at it that the first two
days day and a half sometimes one day in
certain groups of a week-long event
is about retiring that past finishing it
you know this is when the story ends
this is when they get over it now the
next five days
the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genes they're going to be
interchanged to brain circuitry their
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression they're telling me
is it's all going to happen they're
they're more of that future self and and
they're they're headed to a future now
here's the deal though
you got to be able to sustain that state
when you return back to your life that's
the name of the game you got to be able
right you got to bring the game into
your life now and no person no
circumstance no condition in your life
would cause you to feel the old way
again because the moment you started
feeling victimized the moment you
started feeling angry you just return to
the old self you disconnected from the
energy of your future and you're back to
the energy of your past if people are
not aware how can they become aware and
once they become aware what sort of
things should they start to do to start
making those changes
yeah thank you for for teasing that out
that's such a great question you know um
uh my interest is to give people the
tools so that they have within their
reach all the things they need to begin
to apply and become scientists in their
life people don't know if you don't know
that you know those stress hormones are
addictive then you think they have power
over you if you don't think that you can
change your thought just because you
have a thought it doesn't necessarily
mean it's true and the moment I realized
that I was free right and if you isolate
yourself a lot and you don't you're not
out in the world because of whatever
you'll you'll you'll you'll start to
believe every thought that you think is
the truth and so that challenge then of
saying okay
I do truly want to be happy I do truly
want to be healthy I do truly want to
have a life that that is really
empowering that I feel good about okay
well let's take a look like if no
different than
well you use the example of Tiger Woods
no different than Tiger Woods watching
himself swing on a video observing
himself play
no different than a person who stands in
front of an audience and does a lecture
and watches them
do the lecture nobody else will see what
they see they'll see themselves very
differently than anybody else and
they'll they'll see themselves do it and
they'll want to self-correct they'll
want to evolve their experience now
because we got this big frontal lobe 40
of our entire brain that's our
conscience that's a seed of our
awareness that's our creative Center
when we ask the question
what would it be like to be in a
different life or to be happy if instead
of getting on your cell phone or instead
of getting on your social media instead
of turning on the TV or instead of
calling a friend and instead of doing
something to distract you from that
possible answer if you sat with it long
enough in that creative Center turned on
it would naturally scan the whole entire
landscape of the brain because it's the
CEO it's the symphony leader has
connections to all parts of the brain
and it's going to look out over the
landscape of the brain and look at the
knowledge you've learned and the
experiences that are stitched in your
brain that are associated with what you
know to answer that question and as it
calls up these different networks of
neurons once the brain fires in tandem
you get an image or a picture in your
mind and that's called intention you see
a new possibility right so then
this is why I am passionate about what
we're doing I never thought Rankin that
I would see the kind of changes in
people's physical health that I've seen
in the last two years now people do the
best with what they think is available
if you don't know that this is possible
you are going to make the same choice
and that may be relying on some
pharmaceutical something outside of you
some therapy whatever there's nothing
wrong with that
but if your response it hasn't changed
in your life the efficacy of whatever
you're doing is going to be diminished
okay so once I now know that people
could heal from different health
conditions and there's evidence in the
science and there's evidence and
testimony like the person that you just
recited
that's one of many many people that have
had that experience when they stand on
the stage at our week-long Retreats and
we call them up
why do I call them up on the stage
because they are speaking the truth they
are the example of Truth and I want
people to become aware of that
possibility why because if you're
unaware of it it doesn't exist for you
Consciousness is awareness right and so
then with Consciousness you can't have
Consciousness without energy so there
that that thought of another possibility
is a different energy it's a different
possibility and and so now once you know
it's possible then
okay now let's get down
to stepping in the footprints that other
people have left behind why if you're
telling the story of your past every
single day and 50 of that isn't even the
truth then you're reliving a miserable
life that you never even had all for the
reason to excuse yourself from change
stop telling the story of your past and
start telling the story of your future
stop Romancing your past and start
Romancing your future why not fall in
love with your future as much as you've
fallen in love with your past I want you
to understand that all of the work
you've been doing in your meditations
whether you're doing a walking
meditation or a seated meditation or
you're overcoming yourself or you
practice connecting uh to that infinite
field of potentials where you'll
experience wholeness
uh these times in particular are the
times that you've been
preparing for and all the work that
you've been doing and now it's time to
live this work and it's time to step out
of fear and separation because you're
only suggestible to information equal to
the emotions that you experience and
that's what programs the autonomic
nervous system into a particular destiny
so when everybody else is experiencing
fear that's the time to experience
courage or to maintain courage everybody
else is in scarcity and lack that is the
time to give and we have to be able to
demonstrate what it looks like to this
world so more and more people are no
longer controlled uh by their
environment
and the circumstances that are outside
of them so think about it uh all of your
work and dedication is for you to
sustain some type of change independent
of the conditions in your environment to
literally be greater than your body and
to be able to sustain that change for a
period of time and uh money people
during a time where they experience
survival will experience separation and
we know what distress hormones do in
survival
and you have been trained very well to
open your hearts and to go against that
primitive nervous system that keeps us
in our animal nature
so step out of the common step out of
the natural and the normal and become
Supernatural and demonstrate what it is
uh to be that to the world so you give
people an opportunity to do the same the
moment we switch on that system for
alert or for emergency
we alter ourselves in some way and and
all of that response that we have to an
environment that we perceive as
threatening or dangerous
um pretty much causes us to move out of
balance and when you're out of balance
you're you're in survival and when
you're in survival
you want to rush to get things done you
can't be present you know you uh you
believe everything that equal to the
feeling of fear or hostility because
information is is relevant to you in
that emotional state so uh teaching
people then that they have some type of
control over that that sympathetic
response that emergency system that
switches on is preparing you for
something you can't predict yeah
something that's an unknown something uh
that you can't control and
um that survival system uh causes us to
move more into our animal nature and
we're tapping our bodies vital resources
for health and regeneration
so short term it's great but you keep
doing it over and over again you start
becoming more and more conditioned to
that Rush of energy
so teaching people how to self-regulate
teaching them how to move back into the
present moment teaching them
that they can shorten their responses
it's it's really not that you react I
mean we all react the question is how
long are you going to react for because
if you keep that reaction going then
then you can't perceive any change in
your environment you won't have any
ability to heal so you become more uh
affected by your environment so simple
process of getting back into the present
moment to
self-regulating trading that fear uh to
for some other emotions yeah and that
that's doing the work and and the
practice and that's what we should be
doing because now we have energy to heal
we have energy from repair we have
energy
um to create now how do you become
Supernatural
well you have to first start doing what
feels unnatural that means when
everybody else is in fear that's when
you show courage when everybody else is
hostile and angry that's the time to
show love and compassion when everybody
else is
um uh in lack in poverty that's the time
to give and and I think that that gives
people permission to do the same because
of mere neurons we want to emulate that
behavior and it counts the most
in those moments doesn't count when
everything is comfortable and okay it
counts the most
when you should be doing something else
and if you're able to go against those
years thousands of years of genetic
programming hardwired into our survival
centers all of a sudden other people
will begin to do the same and you will
see an emergence of a new Consciousness
I wanted people to understand the
science and the relationship that they
have with their body that we have been
unconsciously programmed into believing
that
um something in our outer world has to
change our inner world and it's also
entirely possible when you start
changing your inner world you start
noticing the effects in your inner world
and sometimes in your outer world and
that's when we get really good at this
so I wanted people to understand how to
strengthen their immune system by giving
it the right information the right
emotions and just like we said it coax
the body into beginning to release
chemistry that begins to strengthen our
our T cells and our lymphocytes so one
is called empowering The Power Within
and the other one is called Falling Into
Love uh with your body and both of those
uh one's uh laying down meditation
before you go to bed and the other one
is a seated meditation that you could do
anytime and people have really enjoyed
them and there's the science of course
behind activating that fourth Center and
the thymus gland and thymusin that
begins to activate T cells and
antibodies and that put it all together
and try it out what does gratitude do
for us in replacing that kind of anxiety
and fear well I mean uh we've done
research on gratitude and it's very
interesting because when you receive
something you've just received something
uh when something's happening to you or
something just happened to you that's
favorable you feel this feeling of
gratitude so yes the emotional signature
it's signature emotionally means
something just happened to you or
something is happening to you
so your body is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between an experience in your life that
creates an emotion and an emotion that
you can fabricate by thought alone to
the body it's so objective it's exactly
the same so when people start to feel
gratitude
their body is believing that something
favorable is going to happen to them
or has already happened to them really
the emotional signature of gratitude is
the perfect signature or the state of
energy to receive
so so when we begin to embrace our
future and we give we feel gratitude for
it we will believe that future is more
of a reality because it's equal to the
emotion that we're experiencing but
we're feeling the emotion before the
actual event occurs so gratitude in a
sense you could use it to elevate your
energy and when you do just 10 15
minutes a day
you'll strengthen your immune system by
50 percent that's wow just by having
gratitude for 10 15 minutes yes because
your body starts to put energy right in
your heart center and there's a gland in
there that we talked about in your show
called that plan that has an
endocrinological aspect and
immunological aspect and it begins to
Signal chemicals that tells your T cells
strengthen you got energy to like modify
and create more receptors for anything
coming out and now your inner
environment is doing that and your T
cells make these antibodies these
immunoglobulins that are the body's
natural flu shot it's proteins that
protect cells especially immune cells
and now you have an internal Army an
internal order that that will be greater
than the environment and now you have
now you have strength if it took you
five years
of living in chronic stress and living
and what are the emotions of stress and
survival aggression anger hatred
um competition judgment insecurity Envy
jealousy pain suffering guilt shame fear
anxiety depression hopelessness
powerlessness those are all derived from
the hormones of stress and psychology
calls the normal human States Of
Consciousness those are Altered States
Of Consciousness and so then
if you're living in emergency and your
response
to your co-worker to your boss to the
traffic to the news to whatever it is
weakens the organism and you're
switching on that emergency system over
time no organism can live in emergency
mode for an extended period of time
you're you're drawing from the body's
vital resources and you're converting
all of its energy into chemistry for
some threat real or imagined okay so
then if you keep doing that in chronic
conditions
there's no energy for growth and repair
all of this
scientific
philosophical spiritual theoretical
information
that is so available to us right now
really begins to leave biological
changes within us
because every time you learn something
new
you make a new connection in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
and the Nobel Prize Laureate candel in
the year 2000.
found that when people learn just one
bit of information
they doubled the number of Connections
in their brain from 1300 connections to
2600 connections
but if they didn't review that
information
if they didn't repeat it
if they didn't think about it or
contemplate on it
those circuits pruned apart
within hours or days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections
physical evidence in your brain
as a result of your interaction in the
environment Footprints of consciousness
but if you can take that information
and apply it
personalize it
demonstrate it
modify your behaviors in some way and do
something differently
get your actions equal to your
intentions and your mind and body
working together
you are going to run into a new
experience
and when you're in the midst of an
experience all of your five senses plug
you into the external environment
and as your brain is gathering all this
vital sensory data all that information
rushes back to your brain
in jungles of neurons organize
themselves into Networks
reinforcing the philosophical
information
enriching the circuits in your brain
because that's what experience does
and the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical
and that chemical is called a feeling or
an emotion
and in that moment
you begin to chemically teach your body
to understand what your mind has
intellectually understood
and we could say that knowledge is for
the mind
and experiences for the body I think
there are many modalities that work for
trauma what I've discovered is that
Insight never really changes Behavior
you can see that your father was
overbearing or was an alcoholic or you
could see all these different things you
know like you could come up with the
Insight of all these different things
the problem that I see with people is
then they tend to excuse their change
by saying oh I had a rough childhood
that's why I am the way I am or excusing
their present position so
and again trauma's a difficult thing but
for me
the person who's living by the identity
in their life that they were traumatized
as a child or whatever it is or they've
had a trauma in their life I'm not
saying forget the trauma and create
another emotion I'm saying that the
person who's willing
to go through the emotion
and keep working on lowering the volume
to it look we have had so many people in
this work with brutal pasts really
really difficult pasts
do the work and finally they reach that
point where they just break free from
the emotion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past
and they don't want to change one thing
in their past because it brought them to
this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there
and I just thought I don't know if I can
go any further and they went one more
time
and the body literally was liberated
from the past right because the trauma's
not just in the brain
the trauma stored emotionally in the
body so you want to take the body out of
the past
out of the known
what do you think the body's going to
say if it's been conditioned to be the
mind the unknown is a scary place you
step out into the unknown you're going
to be unprepared for that trauma you
don't know how it's going to happen and
so the person keeps clinging to the
known and but when the person finally
overcomes the emotion
the body literally is freed from the
chains of the past the side effect of
that is seeing the past from a greater
level of Consciousness lo and behold
there goes the Suicidal Tendencies there
goes the dysfunction there goes the
irritable bowel syndrome that's because
the body was still living in that past
event by living by the same emotion so
the research on memory is kind of
fascinating and I just I've studied it
enough and and it
the way we recount the past
is not the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were eight years old
or 12 years old or 20 years old we have
a different brain we have a completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people
they embellished the story
and make it seem even worse than what it
was
but you're really what you're saying is
I changed in those moments and from a
biological standpoint I haven't been
able to change since so let me tell you
why it's been so hard for me to change
and the story becomes dramatized or
embellished and the person Works them up
fire themselves into this emotional
froth and then
fires and wires the same circuits in the
brain and they're actually reaffirming
their limitation now there's nothing
wrong with that I think we're just
taking too long right so
50 of that story isn't even the truth it
means
in a sense we're reliving a miserable
life that we never even had
and we don't want but but the but the
the unknown people would rather cling to
their suffering unless this is not a
judgment we all do this we'd rather stay
in the known
then take a chance in the unknown
because those emotions of survival are
saying what
run from the unknown the unknown is a
scary place so now the unknown you got
to come up against that moment where
you're going to actually leave that
behind and step into the unknown this is
not a intellectual process this is
this is David and Goliath there's a
battle going on when the body keeps
wanting to go back to its familiar State
because it's subconsciously been
conditioned to be the mind to stay in
the known how many people in this
audience
actually believe in the idea that the
way you think has some effect on your
life that's your thoughts create your
life you believe that yes
so how many people here actually woke up
this morning
and consciously created a future
you know the biggest reason why people
don't do it
is because you don't really believe it's
true
you see if you knew on a gut level that
it was absolutely true
would you ever miss a day come on
and would you ever let any thought slip
by your awareness that you didn't want
to experience
so your brain according to Neuroscience
is organized to reflect everything you
know in your life
your brain is a record of your
environment
it's a record an artifact of your past
so if you believe this then then does
your environment control your thinking
or does your thinking control your
environment
so if you wake up in the morning
and you get out of bed on the same exact
side as you did the day before you shut
the alarm clock off with the same finger
you slip into your favorite slippers you
Shuffle into the bathroom and you use
the toilet like you always do
then you walk over to the mirror and you
look at yourself to remember who you are
then you get into the shower and you
wash yourself in the same routine way
then you groom yourself to look like
everybody expects you to look
then you go downstairs and you drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then you drive the work the same way as
you did the day before
you see the same people that push the
same emotional buttons
you do the exact thing that you know how
to do and you memorize and can do so
well that you're an expert at then you
hurry up and rush home so you can hurry
up and check your emails so you could
hurry up and go to bed so you can hurry
up and do it all over again
now here's my question did your brain
change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
actions that create the same experiences
that produce the same emotions but
secretly expecting something to change
in your life would you agree
so then
as the environment turns on different
circuits in your brain you begin to
think equal to your environment as you
see the same people and go to the same
places and do the same things at the
same time it's the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
and as long as you think equal to
everything that's familiar or known to
you what do you keep creating more of
same life now the quantum law is still
applying to you you're just thinking
equal to everything that you know and
you keep creating more of the same
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment and every great person
in history knew this whether it was
William Wallace or Mahatma Gandhi or
Martin Luther King or Queen Elizabeth
the first or Joan of Arc they all had a
vision
they all had an idea couldn't see it
couldn't smell it couldn't taste it
couldn't feel it but it was alive in
their mind
it was so alive in their mind that they
began to live as if that reality was
actually happening now
so can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already happened
Neuroscience says it's absolutely
possible I see your passion your
passionate about what you're doing your
passion in your work is really tangible
and
um
do you see it as a mission are you on a
mission how do you see it unfolding in
the future and
um what is the future of this Mission
look like in respect of your
growing worldwide Community your
scientific research I know it's a lot
and the potential for personal
transformation for me I I do have a
passion and I do have a mission and that
I believe that in order to transform a
culture to transform a community to
transform the world you have to start
with the individual
and so my passion and my interest is
human change human potential human
transformation and um for me that
mission is I believe that if we can
teach people
uh how to heal themselves
[Music]
how to heal others if we can teach them
a new way of life in terms of what is
possible
I think if we can produce outcomes in
seeing people that that demonstrate that
in some way I think it does change
Consciousness so I'm very Mission driven
and I think that the highest form of
motivation is a mission-driven
motivation when you when you have a
vision that's bigger than you and so
um I'm happy to say that that's what
gets me up in the morning that's what
gets my team up in the morning uh that
when we celebrate someone's personal
change or personal transformation
personal healing I think that inspires
us to want to do more of it so
um
that type of personal conviction that
comes with that mission means that every
day you have to get your behaviors to
match that Vision or that mission that
intention
um I think it's important to navigate
with a sense of Ethics a sense of
morality uh and and and to show people
um that you can demonstrate this work by
being examples so how do I see it
affecting our growing Community uh
I think there has to be an emergent
Consciousness on the planet that it
shows people that there's another way of
living and so I'm so proud of our
community because we're doers we do the
work we practice uh being creators of
our lives and I think it's important to
show people in the world what love does
that if we want forgiveness in the world
we have to show people what forgiveness
looks like if we want to heal the world
then we have to heal ourselves if we
want peace in the world we have to show
the world what peace looks like we have
to demonstrate that and I think because
an emerging Consciousness comes out of
that
now Consciousness is an awareness and
the awareness that there's another way
to live uh and another way to thrive I
think
um gives people permission to to believe
that it's possible so we have this
emergent Community you know this this
emerging Consciousness that really is
about being at cause in their life
instead of being at effect and I think
that each individual
in our community is a representation of
the whole so if you're working on
overcoming your fear or your pain or
your past or trauma that's happened to
you if you're working on overcoming a
health condition
um and I'm working on my own thing and
if we're truly truly on that that path
uh I what what comes out of that is
human goodness to overcome the body
takes a will that's greater than the
program to to no longer get up and run
through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants to in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say way way way
wait a second here we're not going
anywhere until I get clear on who I want
to be today and every time you execute
that will that's greater than the
program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because
doing it you're actually that is the
process right there there's no such
thing as a bad meditation what you're
doing is actually exactly what you need
to do and every time you do that you
become conscious that you go unconscious
that's how you actually develop the
skill of Consciousness it's not being
conscious it's catching yourself when
you go unconscious and people if they
can see the thing is the unconscious
essentially conscious is connecting to
everything which is in the space of
nothingness really there's a journey to
get there yeah and if you're patient
with yourself and you see that
as a victory
like oh you start getting aroused you
start getting frustrated and you think I
can't do this and you go oh no no no no
no no no no we're not going to quit here
that would be me getting up as the same
person I'm curious what's on the other
side of this frustration you settle your
body back down into the present moment
you unfold back into that Eternal space
I'm telling you every time you do that
it's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and it actually turns out that the
body starts liberating energy it starts
real liberating energy but like an
unbridled stallion it goes oh really you
think that's all you think that's all
you have watch this and then it starts
bringing up memories of the past and all
of that just to feel an emotion and if
you're aware that it's doing that and
you settle it down you're taming the
animal you're teaching it you're you're
teaching it how to change its state
right and guaranteed if you keep doing
that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in seven days we see that not only
their dramatic biological changes to
suggest that the person for an
environment
but it it goes for the majority of
people
that immerse themselves in going all in
and what does that mean a different
environment they're in a ballroom
they're on a ballroom I've been to
thousands of ballrooms there's nothing
really exciting in a ballroom what's
exciting in the ballroom they all look
the same but the data suggests that
they're in a whole new environment where
where is that where is that taking place
it's taking place from within the person
those died internal world is of course
everything everything open you gotta go
out into life and try it out okay I've
changed my internal State you could have
a great meditation you can connect your
heart could open this happen to me you
could open your heart you'd be amazing
you'll feel like a day is invincible and
you get up and then the rest of your day
you're unconscious of the 15 hours of
your day so you're going to wait one
hour
of being in a different state of being
against 15 hours of you being unhappy
and rushing and in a program so then
how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's called change how
many times do we have to go unconscious
to the point where we no longer go
unconscious and we stay conscious that's
the moment of change now if you're truly
out of the bleachers and you're on the
playing field and this happens to a lot
of people in our work they say you know
I really believe that this is the truth
I really believe that you could heal
yourself I really believe you could
change your life I've seen the
testimonials
I just never believed that it could
happen to me now this is a big moment
now you're really stepping on the
playing field so
a person who starts doing their work
they're not they're not interested in
healing the true the person who's truly
interested in this work they understand
that the only way they can heal
is that they have to change
they're not saying I'm going to wait for
my wealth or my healing to happen in
order for me to feel grateful and be
joyful in life they're saying I feel
grateful my healing is going to begin
right if I if I feel more whole then
there should be some change in my gene
expression so they've studied the
content they've studied the information
and now it becomes extremely practical
so they may have a great meditation and
we've seen this happen to many people
they sleep better
they have less pain they have more
energy but their blood values never
change
now they don't say oh
I feel better but I'm failing this
doesn't work they say what is it about
me
that's stopping this from completely
healing okay how am I
in my waking day the moment you begin to
ask that question you turn on the
frontal lobe and the frontal lobe is the
seat of your conscience now the moment
you start looking at at the end of your
day how did I do this is such an
important question how'd I do today did
I fall from grace when did I lose it and
who did I lose it with I had another
opportunity how would I do it
differently they'll tell you I've seen
them stand on the stage and tell their
story and say
I had to start really watching myself in
my life how I was emotionally responding
to my ex how I was emotionally
responding to my financial problems I
had to really really pay attention that
and that takes an enormous amount of
energy
and an enormous amount of awareness to
stop the program right so you forget and
you go damn I went unconsciously no you
didn't lose you didn't fail
he just became conscious now if you keep
becoming so conscious of your
unconscious States you're you're outside
the program you're only in the program
when you're unconscious the moment
you're conscious you can objectify your
subjective self so you can see yourself
Through The Eyes of someone else so the
learning process comes from the mistake
the brain learns by mistakes and
surprises I've made enough of them in my
life it's just whether you're going to
do it again yeah you want to do it again
you're back in the habit back in the
routine if you say this is it the next
time that happens I am not going to do
that not for anybody else
but because those emotions actually my
response to that person or that
circumstance is actually weakening the
organism is that person that
circumstance worth it so then
it's Evolution it's Evolution the
challenge then has to be met with a
greater level of mind now if you're just
doing your meditation just because you
want to please God or do the right thing
or feel good about yourself that's going
to get stale after a while because it's
just going to become another routine
between your coffee and your shower and
your emails and your drive to work and
people aren't present right so so the
familiar past conditioning is based on
the past that thought and the feeling
but habituation is the programming them
to predictable future that's the known
so if you teach a person how to find the
present moment that's where the unknown
exists and that takes that takes a lot
of energy and a lot of awareness and yet
if you practice it the body literally
will begin to respond to the mind it's
like training an animal it finally
relaxes and when that occurs your
response to people and circumstances in
your life will be different because you
overcame yourself at the beginning of
the day the hardest part
about change
is not making the same Choice as you did
the day before
that's the hardest part
and you see 95 percent of Who You Are
is a set of unconscious thoughts
behaviors and emotions
and the moment you start becoming
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts the more
aware you are of them the less
unconscious you go
in every single person
in this room
at some time in their lives
has done something great
and you know the problem
is that the brain
is organized to reflect everything you
know in your life
your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of everything you've learned and
experienced to this moment
and of feelings and emotions
are the end product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you remember how they feel
if you're feeling the same way every
single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those emotions are driving your
thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
or feelings have become the means of
thinking are you thinking in the future
are you thinking in the past
come on
the emotion is a record of the past and
those emotions are driving your thoughts
then you're thinking in the past
and if you told me that you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny the law still applies
but sure keep creating your past over
and over again if you study the
Neuroscience of culture you know it's so
so unique because we have we share the
same biology we share the same brain and
because we share the same biology in the
same brain we we have certain Universal
traits that are that are unique to human
beings we smile on we're happy we frown
and we're sad we sleep at night for the
most part we grab a stick with an
opposing thumb so structure and function
are highly related and those are
Universal traits and then we have our
individual traits and that's kind of
like how the brain is wired right that's
like our fingerprint as opposed to our
hand right so
we have an individual series of traits
and that make us unique and we have our
Universal traits but what Bridges the
universality of us the commonalities
human beings with our individuality and
that's culture and culture really is
defined for the most part by the past
what has worked over Generations or
Traditions that have sustained the
culture based on one thing
and that one thing is in environment so
a culture in Northern Mongolia is
certainly different than a culture in
central Mexico because it's a different
environment and those different Customs
that are created from that environment
allow that culture to sustain itself so
look at look at great people in history
that that change the culture whether it
was Gandhi whether it was William
Wallace whether it was Joan of Arc
whether it was Martin Luther King
whoever it was that changed the culture
what they did really well is they showed
people that there was an alternative
future that they could actually believe
or perceive in their mind now you can't
see that future if you're living by the
same emotions of the past and for most
people they live by the emotions of the
past what you have to do is you got to
get people out of their resting state
they have to become inspired they have
to become enthusiastic and Theos filled
with God they have to become motivated
in some way they have to be moved and
when they are moved emotionally then
that that that energy that emotion
causes them to see the same future as
that leader sees and you when you get
people seeing that same future and they
have that clear intention and you
combine that with a different emotion
you're changing people's state of being
now get enough people doing that
and what he what happens is you get an
emergent Consciousness an emergence in
biology is such a phenomenal thing
because when you see a group of birds or
a flock of birds flying in the same
direction or a school of fish moving
together they appear as a larger
organism when you study that principle
and biology you think that there's a
leader that everybody's following that
it's a top-down phenomenon in fact it's
not it's a bottom-up phenomenon and
everybody's leaving leading everybody's
behaving in the same way and the
appearance of a larger organism becomes
more sustainable for that species so
we have such a stigma in our minds that
if you lead with too much passion you're
going to get it in the end whether
you know Jesus Christ or Abraham Lincoln
or uh William Moss whoever it was the
the outcome for truth is usually you
lose your life
but the real question is what if
everybody's leading
you just can't take out everybody now so
so this is a really important time
because the emergent Consciousness that
has to take place has to be built on
principles and the principles that
people can actually wrap their mind
around
they have to keep their mind on it for a
period of time where they're not
distracted by technology they're not
distracted by Tick Tock and they're not
distracted by social media and they're
not distracted by the news that that
that the the eminent condition of the
world right now and the way things are
going based on self-interests
are all based on survival and you can
control people
when you control their emotions and when
you control their emotions you control
their attention and if you can capture a
person's attention you can capture their
energy because where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and so you could actually program people
to do anything
based on the emotion that they feel and
fear is a great emotion to cause people
to rely on some authoritative figure to
lead them away so
if there's a new Consciousness that
emerges that that is based on not fruits
and nuts and not uh you know not on
crystals not on colonics not on any of
those things but this is game time this
is where something else has to be born
in human beings that has already innate
in us uh and that is the power to
organize as a species when we begin to
heal one another when we begin to inform
one another and begin to respect one
another when we begin to shine from one
another when we begin to stand up for
one another one begin to abilities and
then damage
two people that there are other ways of
doing things and share that right
information I think an emerging
Consciousness will actually take place
and
God I think this is the time in history
more than ever uh where where it matters
the most well there's two really
two specific paradigms of reality
that are about what's called Newtonian
physics which is cause and effect that
you know something happens to us in our
environment but the experience happens
it changes us internally and
condition and when we react to the
condition we begin to function at a fact
of something outside of us if something
good happens to us and we react
positively then we give thanks after the
experience happens really but either way
we're pretty much victims of Destiny the
quantum model of reality sense that mind
and matter aren't separately that that
subjective mind somehow has an effect on
the enchanted world so then
if you begin to piece this together
you can have a clear intention of what
you want
but then to move into the state of how
you would feel if it already happened
gratitude is an emotional signature that
the event is already done so if you can
teach your body emotionally what it
feels like
to have the event already happen and you
can get in touch with that then your
body is the unconscious mind doesn't
know the difference between the
experience that produces the emotion and
the emotion that you fabricate or create
by thought alone and when we move into a
state of being where mind and body are
working together are our thoughts and
feelings are aligned so there are
biological changes that happen in the
brain and body and we move into that
state of being and when we're in that
state of being the universe begins to
organize itself to reflect a new state
of being our sexuality our consumption
of food our our ability to use our will
to overcome the conditions in our
environment most people live by these
centers here these are centers of
awareness centers of energy and each one
every thought that you have produces a
frequency so this is what we call the
zero point field it is the Quantum field
the unified field the energy that
connects everything material it is the
consciousness of the all in all it is
Oneness wholeness Universal Mind
infinite intelligence zero point field
the unified field Source Observer the
void the fertile void all possibilities
the Eternal now the infinite unknown the
very life force that holds everything
together and it's a unifying field and
scientists have been trying to unify the
principles and the energy of the
universe to explain how matter exists
are you with me still so energy then the
zero point field slows down in frequency
and it reaches a certain point and at
this level there's an explosion called
The Big Bang and all of a sudden energy
can't slow any anymore before it divides
and becomes polarized and the patterns
of everything material exists at the
speed of light and it's the patterns
then that slow energy down to take form
and structure that ultimately peers
matter now
all of us the Divine aspect of ourselves
came from this Universal intelligence
and we came all the way down into
density and this is the realm of our
senses and we can experience the
three-dimensional reality with our
senses and we spend our whole life being
a somebody or having some type of body
or knowing someone or being someone
owning certain things living somewhere
in some time and this becomes the
identity are you with me still
so then
people then spend the majority of their
life living in this way and they
experience from matter the greatest
separation from the unified field
here is source and if you're living as a
body local in space and time you're
experiencing a separation between you as
a Consciousness and the consciousness of
the unified field so when you're living
in a body and space and time it takes a
long time for your dreams to happen are
you with me still so if you're thinking
certain thoughts and certain thoughts
produce certain feelings you're taking a
thought and you're beginning to store it
as energy or emotion in one of these
centers and most people are thinking in
these first three centers and when they
do they're storing energy in their first
three centers and their bodies being
conditioned to be the mind
it takes opening this Center to begin to
the creative process this is the center
of Oneness this is the center of
wholeness this is the union of polarity
and Duality and if you can't get energy
into your heart then for the most part
then it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart to begin to affect the
nature of reality to begin to affect
matter are you with me still
so then every thought that you think
produces a frequency and most people's
frequencies most people's thoughts are
in this realm right here and would make
sense then if they're thinking slower
thought frequencies then it's going to
take a long time for their dreams to
come true when people
first thing they have to do is they have
to overcome their survival States they
have to over overcome their programs
they're going to be willing to sit with
themselves long enough to wonder what's
on the other side of I can't or it's too
hard or I want to give up or this sucks
what's on the other side of those
thoughts those are just program thoughts
what's on the other side of this emotion
called guilt or this emotion called
frustration what's on the other side of
it right so you get people to a certain
point and give them a little bit of help
but the key then is we've done we've
done studies on this
if you close your eyes and you place
your attention on your heart
turns out where you place your attention
is where you place your energy right so
if you can put your attention on your
heart and not your cell phone
and you can keep it on your heart and
and feel it and experience it and pay
attention to it by paying attention to
your heart you're actually giving it
your energy now your heart tends to feel
different emotions uh than other parts
of your body and what emotions it loves
to feel is love Compassion Care kindness
gratitude inspiration Freedom these are
elevated emotions
so if you could put your attention on
your heart we see from the technology
that we built in time and not a very
long amount of time just a few minutes
you'll start to see this very low
frequency of the heart start going up
which means the the energy that's
indigenous to the heart with the heart
uses only you're actually feeding it
energy right so if you do that then and
then you can slow your breathing down
when you slow your breathing down you
slow your brain wipes down we've measure
that thousands of times so instead of
this short breath or this instead of
this kind of shallow breath
really work on taking long slow breaths
through your heart inhale with the
intention of relaxing hold it with the
intention of relaxing while you hold it
exhale with the intention of relaxing
blow all the air out hold it for a few
seconds you're not going to die relax
again inhale again and just do a series
of three or four or five or six of these
depending on working with your body so
that it starts to feel safe again that's
what it is it's slow your brain waves
down you slow your breathing down you
slow your breathing down you convert
from the sympathetic
to the parasympathetic and that's what
we see then all of a sudden we see the
person's parasympathetic nervous system
go up and sympathetic goes down what
does that mean
they're not moving out of stress okay
the body's moving into that state of
growth and repair now put your attention
on your heart now do something really
cool amplify that's the amplifier that's
the creative Center so what do you want
to feel like what emotion do you want to
feel when a future experience happens
whatever that is feel the Gratitude feel
the joy feel the freedom and breathe and
feel and feel and breathe and keep
relaxing into your heart keeping your
attention nowhere else out of the
millions of things you can put your
attention on that's your Target and you
work with your body and your breathing
you feel as you start relaxing into your
heart you keep working on relaxing into
your heart and you feel it you feel that
emotion there'll come a moment where
that energy will naturally start moving
up to the brain and when that happens
the survival centers shut down brain
moves into Alpha you see more in
pictures and images you could take it
it's like a taking a sheet of paper a
sheet on a bed and going like this the
heart sins is propagating wave right
into the brain just it follows boom
right after the stroke volume and it's
telling the brain to be creative to
dream to be you know to be unlimited so
the more you do that here's the key
the more you do it the more it becomes a
skill now
when a person has a panic attack right
what they do is they mismanage their
attention they they picture the worst
scenario that could possibly take place
and then they say no what if this
happens what if this happened what if
this episode they're making it actually
10 times worse because if you prepare
for the worst there's always better
chances of survival the problem is
they're combining that image in their
mind and they're actually living the
experience emotionally
and so they're taking that thought and
that feeling that image and that emotion
that stimulus and response and they're
conditioning the body subconsciously to
become the mind of fear
after a certain point when the body's
that out of balance it will have a panic
attack try as you may to control it with
your conscious mind can your program it
subconsciously then it gets worse
because after that one you can't
anticipate when the next one's going to
happen so you start getting ready for
the next one and that's what exactly
starts the cycle okay so what we
discovered that the more you relax into
your heart and feel these elevated
emotions it's exactly like a panic
attack only it's a love attack the
emotional signature of gratitude means
something's happening to you
something has happened to you you're
receiving something or you just receive
something so your body then when you're
feeling gratitude is in the perfect
state of receiving so then that means
then
you'll accept believe and surrender to
the thoughts equal to the emotional
state of gratitude if you're living in
resentment you're living in fear you're
living in in patience you could say I'm
healthy I'm healthy I'm healthy I'm
wealthy I'm wealthy I'm with all you
want and that thought's going to stop
right at the brain stem and never make
its way to the body because the body is
not failure because why because you're
feeling resentment and that thought
isn't that thought is not consistent
with the emotion of resentment
resentment has a different set of
thoughts right in other words once you
start opening your heart
it begins to move into coherence it
begins to produce a measurable magnetic
field up to three meters wide now that's
frequency that's energy and all that
energy that frequency carries
information carries an intent so then
when you're feeling gratitude and your
heart is open you're broadcasting energy
into the field the frequency the
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of your health or your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering you
can't the suffering does not carry that
energy does not carry the thought of
your wealth it carries a different set
of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated right
right and you better know how to
self-regulate and you have to know the
moment you disconnect from the energy of
your future because of some circumstance
in your life and you lose that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change the the
frustration from some experience in your
life back to the energy of your future
now
that requires Great awareness and great
effort but if you have a commune of
people that are practicing this on a
daily basis and they're connected to
their future because that's where their
their mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past when
you're in the state of survival
you're not going to learn you're not
going to want to create you're not going
to want to go within you're not going to
want to open your heart you're not going
to want to be vulnerable it's not the
time to do that in stress it's time to
run to hide or to fight and so people
spend 70 percent of their life living in
the state and as they begin to get
caught up in these chemicals what they
start doing is out of the infinite
possibilities in the quantum field that
they can begin to create in stress you
will select the worst case scenario
and when you select the worst case
scenario you're in survival because in
survival if you prepare for the worst
there's better chances of surviving so
people are always picking the worst
reality in their mind and combining a
thought with the emotion and their
conditioning their body into a genetic
Destiny how many people are with me
so then
separation means I'm here and you're
there and if you look any different than
me then I'm going to experience a little
bit more separation and if you have a
different skin color I hear a different
race or you you look different than me
then I'm going to experience more
separation and then there's me here one
point of Consciousness and you there
another point of Consciousness but then
there's me here and there's my dreams
and where do we place our dreams way out
there
because we experience time linear so we
make an estimate in our mind it's going
to take me a lot of time to get what I
want so here's one point of
Consciousness and then your dreams are
another point of Consciousness way over
there and it's going to cause you to
drag your body through space every
single day to go to work to pay off all
the dreams that you're creating because
your matter trying to change matter we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your DNA get longer that
means your biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal I
mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there then you
take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with Parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with with
lupus with Ms with brain injuries with
rare genetic disorders with vertigo uh
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event and then at
the end of that event they make
significant strides in getting beyond
the emotions of the past now think about
this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that Gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
Gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion well now they're dialing down
the gene for Ms and they're up
regulating the gene for health and
balance and so the person will you'll
say to them where's the disease well I'm
not the same person I'm not just and and
the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now what they're talking about
is how amazing they feel because they're
refreshed they're they're they got a new
lease on life and so now we have
evidence in our research
and that silences the critic to show
that what's possible for people I just
think that there's more to reality than
we perceive and I think it's an instinct
in our mind it's an intuition in our
heart that never seems to go away and I
think it's that feeling that brings
people uh to the to to to Really that
process of discovery they may not be
able to explain it or put it into words
but they feel it and they felt that
their entire lives and what that feeling
is is that this isn't this cannot be the
end this it just can't be so and so what
do I find so promising is that
uh I said to my scientific team the
other day I said I can't believe this is
the truth I really cannot believe this
is the truth I mean what was once
considered pseudoscience we now have
data my one of our top scientists did a
presentation a couple weeks ago and his
last line this is a very well published
guy 175 papers his last line is you are
what you think that was his last line I
looked at him and I thought who is this
Buddha on the stage like I cannot
believe we can begin to make measurable
changes uh in reality by allowing
ourselves to create a new personality so
if you begin to see that what you're
doing inside of you changing how you
think you feel produces an effect
outside of you you're no longer
a victim of cause and effect but now
you're causing enough so in order to
explain the answer to that question you
have to merge several different
idealisms in quantum physics to
neuroscience and mind to the
neuroendocrinology of emotions how
emotions signals genes genes prepare the
body you know for its Destiny so I think
the best way to describe it is is that
when we move into a new state of being
and we're no longer thinking acting and
feeling in the same way
there should be physiological and
physical changes as a result of it if we
just simply make different choices
because we're being differently we're
certainly going to head to in the future
the hardest part about all of this
is making a different choice and the
moment you decide to make a different
Choice get ready it's going to feel
uncomfortable right it's going to feel
unfamiliar your your body's all of a
sudden saying hey Louis why don't you
start thinking those same exact thoughts
do the same things make the same choices
that demonstrate the same behaviors have
the same experiences so you could feel
that feeling of lack complain again to
somebody call somebody up and say how
miserable your life is right and that's
that's the known right so the body is
always influencing the mind to return
back to the familiar territory the
default is the default okay
all right so now the person says
okay what thoughts do I not want what
what would an abundant person think this
way the people in our work that have
created I had a guy come to our event I
I love this guy he healed himself he
tried to take his life three times when
he told me that when he came to our work
he didn't have two dollars to rub
together he's worth hundreds of millions
of dollars and just keeps
giving it away wow
his his lesson his lesson was and that
wasn't the wealth it was who he became
so it's the overcoming process
that is the becoming process who did he
become in that Journey exactly he had to
get beyond all of those thoughts of this
past all the mistakes he made all the
things he did wrong all the money he
owed there all of that that was like he
just had to no longer be that person any
longer but he did say
how would a wealthy person live and and
and when he created his wealth what do
you think the first thing he did
started giving giving it away why
because an abundant person doesn't have
any lack and he knows how to create more
of it than this he's in the experiment
well what would happen if I keep giving
it away he keeps getting more that's a
good experiment to have because that he
is actually living in that abundant
State he also had tremendous healings
taking place because when you heal your
heart heal your mind I mean it's just
the way it is we saw it so many times
right so he healed his heart he's got an
upgrade he got an upgrade
we know according to the epigenetic
model that the environment signals the
gene without a doubt
and then products of an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so by people sustaining elevated
heart-centered emotions and getting
really good at doing it with our eyes
open they're signaling genes ahead of
their environment and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of the
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life now when the
person understands if I live by this
emotional state every single day and my
body's so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating this emotion yes and the
emotion that I'm fabricating by thought
alone and they assign meaning to the ACT
I'm doing this because I want to Signal
new genes the moment they assign meaning
to the ACT they switch on their
prefrontal cortex and they get greater
value from the act that means then they
start noticing that their pain levels
start to diminish that their range of
motion starts to improve that they're
sleeping better
uh that they feel more calm and more
present the moment they notice those
changes that are happening now their
meditation becomes even more thoughtful
even more powerful because now they're
noticing the effects of them themselves
that cause they're not waiting for their
healing
to feel wholeness and gratitude they
understand that feeling wholeness and
gratitude is actually creating their
healing which is a Quantum principle
which you in the quantum you got to feel
it first to experience before you
experience it so but but if you don't
know that then you're waiting for your
out of something in your outer World to
Change or waiting for something to
change in your biology in order for you
to feel gratitude or feel whole and
that's just the old model of of cause
and effect the the quantum model about
causing an effect
the challenge is that there's a period
of going from the old self to the new
self that is that unknown place where
you're always looking and when the
moment you're looking you're separate
from it so it takes training it takes
practice and we know that if a person
immerses themselves in a retreat for
three days or seven days and we give
them the the knowledge and we use
science as that model when we combine
quantum physics with neuroscience and
neuroendocrinology and psychonic
Immunology in uh epigenetics we we in my
electromagnetism we give them that
knowledge and information and if
knowledge is power knowledge about
yourself is self-empowerment so and the
mind can rest and and the mind can
actually understand what it's doing and
why it's doing and when you understand
the what and the why the how it gets
easier and doesn't matter how sick you
are it doesn't matter how old you are
how in shape you are how out of shape
you are if you ever meditated before
we've got the data to show that none of
those things actually matter it's just
really understanding the process and
giving people
numerous opportunities to overcome
themselves now what's your environment
made of objects things places bodies
people right so it's very material okay
so now right the arousal causes us to
pay more attention to the outer world
and less attention to our inner world
and this Rush of chemicals causes us to
become very preoccupied with trying to
make that feeling of survival and stress
go away so time becomes very relevant as
well so now your body is where you put
your attention your environment is where
you put your attention and your
attention is on time well it turns out
to change is actually to be greater than
your body to be greater than your
environment and be greater than time so
if people are spending the majority of
their life with the emergency system
switched on
it's not a time to create it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to go
within it's not a time to meditate it
goes against the survival Gene that says
you will be prey it's not a time to open
your heart it's not a time to commune
it's not even a time to eat look at the
last few years yeah so people spend the
majority of their time shutting uh let
me say it another way so then so then
when a person is living in survival and
they're trying to control and predict
and change everything that's going on in
their life every person that they know
every object or thing that they own
every place that they know or have lived
or go to and everything they've
experienced in their past they're going
to try to predict in their future so now
the arousal of stress hormones causes
the brain to fire out of order because
every person every object every thing
has a different neurological Network in
the brain now the brain is firing in
coherently and when it's firing in
coherently we're incoherent at the same
time you're sitting in the zoom meeting
and it's not T-Rex it's your co-worker
and you're actually producing the same
chemicals as if you're being chased by
T-Rex but you don't you're not running
you're not fighting
you're not hiding you're doing sitting
there and those those chemicals are
running through the body and the heart
is actually pumping really hard because
it's turned on and it's got a run fight
or hide and you're sitting there
and the heart is actually pumping
against the closed system and the Heart
starts to become incoherent and when
incoherence takes place in the heart the
interference of of waves actually causes
energy to drop in the heart so now you
have no energy in the heart you have no
energy in the brain and now the person
is living in their animal self in that
animal nature right and so they're
waiting for something to change in their
outer world
they're waiting for something to change
in their outer world to take away this
feeling of fear or anxiety or
frustration or impatience or resentment
or pain or suffering or guilt or shame
and they're living by that emotional
state and they would rather cling
to those memories and those emotions
because at least it's the known right
and it's survival
why because in survival the unknown you
better run from the unknown there's
better chances of survival so nobody
takes a chance right okay so so then
back to the 3D World then
the Newtonian world the classical world
of quantum physics is all about
Newtonian physics is all about the
predictable right and we can shoot a
rocket to the moon if we know the
distance and the speed of the rocket we
can determine the time it's going to
take to get there so this
three-dimensional reality is all about
predictions right okay well you can get
what you want but you got to work really
hard and it's going to take a lot of
time and energy you can develop the
skills to get it okay now so is there
possibly another way to do it I mean
okay let's look at another way is there
another way to actually
do it in a shorter amount of time to
shorten the distance between the thought
of what you want and the experience of
having it between the cause and the
effect from one point of Consciousness
uh I'm here and another point of
Consciousness I want the experience of
this here is there a way to do that okay
well let's unpack the whole model of
quantum physics
okay so you look at it Adam an atom is
99 99
nothing and I say nothing I mean it's
energy it's nothing it's a point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent physical and material and it is
yeah that's what we're made of and it's
a scientific fact it's the the
mathematics prove that we're perceiving
less than one percent of reality okay so
what we're perceiving then is the
frequency of light the wavelength of
light coming off the sun which is the
the rainbow bouncing off of objects that
give us the illusion of Separation in
three-dimensional reality okay that's
that's what we're seeing right we're
seeing and experiencing the material
world by light being being projected
onto it
take away the light out of
three-dimensional reality
um you don't really have a whole lot of
experience of it you bump into a lot of
things I mean take away all light okay
so so the the atom is both particle
material and wave and what's wave what
is wave frequency what is frequency
energy what is frequency and energy do
they carry information okay so the
quantum field then is that invisible
field of energy a frequency that exists
beyond our senses that we're not
perceiving but it still exists just
because we're unaware of it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist okay so
how much of your waking day in your
Waking Life do you put your attention on
matter
and how much of your waking data you put
your attention on frequency and energy
well throw in the hormones of stress
and your attention is on your body on
the environment in time where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy so now all of your energy and
attention is is invested in this
three-dimensional reality and it appears
really real because that's where our
attention is meditation number one means
become familiar with uh but
transformation and change means as I
said to be greater than your environment
uh and what is your environment made of
objects things people places to be
greater than your body the habituations
and emotional conditioning and to be
greater than time so meditation then is
a great way to close your eyes and
disconnect from your outer world and
whether you play music or where your
phone's disconnect from your known uh um
outer environment not hearing
distractions and
um and sounds and and to sit your body
down and so that it's not eating and
tasting and smelling and experiencing
and feeling and and not think about
what's going to happen on your schedule
in the future and not keep remembering
what happened to you in the past keep
keep working for the sweet spot of the
generous present moment
um
and so then
by doing this
uh and practicing disconnecting from
your body your environment and time uh
people can begin to focus on their inner
world and when they do that properly we
we now know that as you begin to reduce
the stimulation your brain waves begin
to slow down and and the purpose of
meditation is to get beyond the
analytical mind and what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is that analytical mind and
learning how to slow your brain waves
down into slower frequencies begins to
open the door between the conscious mind
and subconscious mind and now you can
rewrite a new program now you can
rehearse a new track now you can record
a new future and you begin to program
your subconscious
um become more naturally who you want to
be we really think that you know
everything's going to be handed to us or
we can get whatever we want nothing
wrong with that that's really cool
that's really great but in the creative
process
you actually have to get outside of time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so yes
there is a function of three-dimensional
reality and Technology where more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time certainly there's some type of
energetic thing that's taking place uh
in so many ways and to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be that's what I believe so if you want
to be a victim get ready because it's
going to get really good for you because
that energy is more available if you
want to heal wow there's a lot of people
healing now and they're using that
energy instrumentally in a positive way
so so yes there's a quickening that's
taking place and it's creating quite a
contrast or extremes that are taking
place in reality and the more extreme it
gets the more unstable the system right
so uh governments
um
um journalism
education religion medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
uh instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
I think that amazing things happen and
that's exactly what we're discovering
over and over again in just witnessing
the the science
is absolutely supporting that that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more unlimited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind the events follow-ups were
actually created by our community
because they're a real passion and
interest was to get together again with
the community and so we created these
events follow-ups for people to come
dressed as their future selves and then
we would Advance the understanding of
the retreat that they had been part of
that year
and go a little further to apply the
formula a little bit further to see
what's possible by doing it and I want
people to come that really want to be
there
I want people to come that really have
been practicing something that they're
after the mystical they're after healing
whatever it is
[Music]
and then we can go a little further down
that rabbit hole and see what's possible
and so they're designed for advanced
students that want to deepen their
understanding and a lot of times I try
out a lot of new things just to see if
it's possible the Journey Back To Source
the journey back to Oneness the Journey
Back everybody gets to you can be
anybody you want to be in three
dimension you can be any character you
want to be in the virtual reality
experiences a simulation that we're
experiencing
but if you're living by the same
emotions every day
or you can't get out of bed because you
can predict the feeling of everything
that's going to happen in your life then
nothing's going to change until you
change and the discovery of okay
most people have to hit their lowest
point in their life where that nothing's
making that feeling go away to finally
look at how they think look at how they
act look at how they feel my message is
why wait for that like and so what we're
discovering is in seven days in seven
days the science that we have
is so compelling to show that in seven
days there will be a host of biological
changes that take place in a person's
body to actually look like they're
living in a new environment living in a
whole new life
so then
getting over yourself to answer your
question is the difficulty that's why
people will say it's too hard for me but
what they're really saying is I don't
believe in that I don't really don't
believe in it because if you believe in
it
you got to show up and if you don't
believe in it then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself that means you don't believe in
possibility if you don't believe in
possibility that means you can't believe
in yourself because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to get some incredible Eckhart
Tolle motivation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there talking about past and future and
excessive emphasis on past and future in
your life if there's nothing wrong with
having a certain in intention of what
you want to achieve take steps towards
it it's part